іноземні
вчені та підприємці з
готовими наукомісткими рішеннями
зможуть представити свої стартапи
та налагодити проекти поза треком Agra та Bill,
а сім проектів із
стеку Health отримають фінансову підтримку в
розмірі п’яти тисяч доларів кожен для
розвитку інноваційного проекту  ми
хочемо висловити нашу вдячність нашим
чудовим партнерам, з якими ми організовуємо
цю серію заходів
на мороз, велику подяку Міністерству
цифрової трансформації України,
Міністерству освіти і науки
України за підтримки
партнера USF Global Innovation  через
науку та технології, а зараз я маю
честь надати слово для
вступного слова
першому заступнику Міністра освіти і
науки України Транко Андре, ласкаво
просимо, дякую,
шановні учасники, організатори та
партнери Science and Business GIS
tphd  Я вітаю вас з початком
заходу урок це науковці та
підприємці з готовими каже
інтенсив Рішення за можливість
присутності та стартапи та як переможці
отримують фінансову підтримку для
розвитку своїх інновацій Хочу
підкреслити актуальність
сьогоднішнього заходу  для посту для вежі
України
Інноваційні проекти в галузі охорони здоров’я
технології біотехнології енергетика та
Технологія промисловість та інфраструктура
представить його сьогодні,
а Доплер є підтримкою інновацій
Інноваційні проекти в цих напрямках
дуже важливі, тому що
збереження життя людей відновлення більш
постраждалих регіонів України розвиток
Технології, що вирішують глобальні проблеми
людства,
такі питання, як харчування,
енергетичні мінеральні ресурси та вдосконалення
системи охорони здоров’я та догляду за навколишнім
середовищем,
це саме для вирішення завдань,
які наука та бізнес. Серія
заходів, організованих міністром
освіти Мозок вбивці  Міністерство
цифрової трансформації та
Український фонд стартапів і надалі
успішно реалізовуються продуктивністю
та науковим та інноваційним потенціалом
науковців стартапи компанії
досвід інвестори і так далі Я також
хочу відправити заходи ідеологічний
партнер глобальна ініціатива «Інновації через
науку та технології» торгівельна
підтримка
ми цінуємо вашу ініціативу та
дуже підтримуємо вашу подальшу
плідну співпрацю. Сподіваюся, що
високий потенціал українських інноваторів
та наукомістких стартапів буде
представлено під час заходу, а найкращий
проект ми отримаємо чудові призи та
шанс реалізувати інноваційні
рішення, тому я  бажаю всім успіху та
слави молитися,
велике спасибі, Генрі, а тепер я маю
честь надати слово Олександру
Барріноко, заступнику міністра цифрової
трансформації України, керівнику
проекту dscd Алексу, будь ласка, привіт
усім,
добре, я, напевно, з тих пір  це відбувається
8 березня, перш за все, я
хотів би привітати всіх жінок з
Міжнародним жіночим днем,
і я завжди радий
брати участь у таких подіях, а ми,
науковці та підприємці, маємо
можливість  розповісти про свої продукти
та залучити фінансування, яке їм, очевидно,
потрібне,
як міністр цифрової
трансформації, у нас є мета вивести
Україну в п’ятірку найкращих країн
Європи, е-е, за кількістю стартапів на чашку
в основному на один мільйон населення,
це базується на величезному потенціалі
українського  Екосистема стартапів і
наукові
проекти є її значною частиною.
Охорона здоров’я розповідає Tech
agri-food Tech robotics клімат тег усе
це є пріоритетними сферами для інвестицій у
всьому світі, а в Україні це один із
найважливіших секторів, на розвиток якого ми маємо
великий вплив.  наша
здатність створювати економіку, тому, коли ми говоримо
про потенційну українську
систему стартапів, ми маємо на увазі принаймні
[Музика]
гм
1 500 технічних стартапів із загальною сумою
приблизно 23 мільярди доларів
згідно з дослідженням Deal Room і
Google для стартапів, тож ми активно
працювали над тим,
в Україні буде ще більше перспективних технічних послуг,
тож сьогодні держава є найбільшим
інвестором-ангелом завдяки Українському
фонду стартапів, який уже надав
суму у розмірі 160 мільйонів Urban
International Investment є ще одним
потужним стимулом для розвитку
українських стартапів  тож ми
співпрацюємо з сотнями компаній,
щоб зустріти їх віч-на-віч із їхнім
венчурним капіталістом за допомогою інвесторів і
торгових виставок, і таким чином українські
початківці зібрали понад 15
мільйонів доларів минулого року,
навіть під час війни ми продовжуємо
зробити це, тому минулого року спільно з
American Venture Capital компанія
венчурного капіталу запустила синьо-жовтий
фонд спадщини з понад 50 мільйонами
доларів, доступними для українських стартапів,
і ми також продовжили наш діалог із
Plug and Play Tech Center, це
інноваційна платформа в Кремнієвій долині
і наша мета полягає в тому, щоб зробити всі
можливості доступними для попередніх
стартапів, і ми повністю віримо, що
Україна може бути і буде місцем,
де народився єдиноріг
[Музика],
і я вірю, що
навіть деякі з вас могли б бути серед цих
єдинорогів, тому я хочу  удачі та
чудових результатів, Глорія Україна,
велике дякую,
велике дякую, Алекс,
для нас велика честь, а тепер я хочу дати
слово наступному спікеру Марку Маріно,
президенту, стратегії росту та
розвитку вентрального клапана Марку  будь ласка,
гаразд,
дякую і гм так, дякую за
ці зауваження, е-е, е-е, е-е, та Андре, ми е-е-е, е-е, пишаємося тим, що
підтримуємо е-е, ту
роботу,
яка тут відбувається, е-е, і всю
вашу роботу, е-е, що відбувається для
підтримки  українські
підприємці-початківці, мене звуть Марк Морено,
я віце-президент із розвитку загальної стратегії
у Venture Well, Venture
Wells, партнер із реалізації від імені Державного
департаменту Сполучених Штатів
для глобальної програми «Інновації через
науку та технології» або просто
гм  як державно-приватне партнерство,
яке надає навчальні мережі та
ресурси для підтримки науково-технічних
підприємців та екосистем і понад
130 економік у всьому світі, започатковане
у 2011 році, ми надали
півмільйона доларів у вигляді призів, скликали 100
заходів і підтримали близько 15  000
наукових і технологічних стартапів і
підприємців,
гм, ми справді принижені та пишаємося тим, що
підтримуємо Український фонд стартапів
Міністерство цифрової інформації та
Міністерство освіти та науки для
наукового та бізнесового простого дня презентації
та справді беремо участь у цьому баченні
розвитку  стійка
гм і значне ех економічне зростання
Українська екосистема
гм ми працюємо в Україні
п’ять п’ять років,
підтримуючи підприємців-засновників і
справді відповідаючи на різні
виклики в екологічній
стійкості, продовольчій безпеці, енергетиці та охороні
здоров’я, надаючи ряд
різноманітні навчальні заходи підтримки, які
підтримують як стартапи, так і
інвесторів і створюють багато того, що було
описано як
стійку та чуйну підприємницьку
екосистему, і те, що ми бачили,
справді є навіть у найскладніші
та найскладніші часи.
Уява та співпраця Ingenuity  в
українській екосистемі стартапів є динамічною
та справді має потенціал для побудови
кращого майбутнього, тому протягом останніх кількох
років і в майбутньому ми
узгодили більше ресурсних
програм і підтримки уряду США, щоб продовжувати
підтримувати цю чудову роботу, яка відбувається в
Україні  Науково-технічні
стартапи та ми впевнені, що
українська підприємницька екосистема
не лише продовжуватиме рости, а й
процвітатиме у наступні роки, тож дякуємо
вам і з нетерпінням чекаємо нових стартапів
та почути більше про презентації.
Дуже дякую, Марк за це
можливість для українських стартапів, а
тепер я радий запросити
магазин Пабло Картера, директор
Українського фонду стартапів Пабло, будь ласка,
привіт
усім, мені приємно бути
присутнім тут сьогодні, і перш за все я
хотів би подякувати
нашим партнерам  по-перше, Міністерство
науки та освіти фактично ці
наукові та бізнес-дослідження було
розпочато спільно,
можливо, рік тому, і це вже, е-е, у
нас уже було дюжина різних
заходів, а по-друге, Міністерство цифрової
трансформації, яке є нашим головним безпечнішим
акціонером, і ми насправді  організовуючи
багато різноманітних заходів і
хакерських точок, і останнє, але не менш важливе,
я хотів би надіслати гостей уряду США
для постійної підтримки, тому що на
даний момент ми
вже запустили багато різних ініціатив, і
суть полягає в тому, що ми
постійно підтримуємо нас і
фінансово підтримуємо стартапи  це дуже
важливо,
що я насправді хотів би сказати,
крім того, що ми шукаємо
стартапи, засновані на технологіях, стартапи,
база знань, стартапи, які працюють
від інститутів, новаторів,
центрів RNG і
[Музика] те,
що ми маємо зараз, у нас є багато
різні партнери, які дивляться
на індустрію глибоких технологій, отже, в основному,
ми почали співпрацю з
Європейським інститутом інновацій і
технологій нещодавно, ми вже провели
хакатон із сировини,
зараз ми готуємо ще кілька заходів,
присвячених харчовим та агротехнологіям, тому ми будемо
продовжуйте цю роботу, і
я буду дуже вдячний, якщо все більше і
більше команд приєднаються до нас і презентуватимуть свої
проекти ідей, тому що, очевидно, ми
шукатимемо подальші інвестиції та
фінансові можливості,
тож бажаю
всім удачі та гарних
персиків,
велике спасибі, Пабло, а тепер
нехай  я представляю ювелірних учасників, які
сьогодні оцінюватимуть стартапи та вирішать, що
ми оберемо фінансування Я
хотіла б представити основних експертів Наталія
Денікєва, директор дирекції ІТ-індустрії,
керівник проектного офісу dscd
Діана Аркос, керівник групи із залучення
інвестицій, яка закінчилася, керівник
освітніх ініціатив  за це Оксана
PhD голова експертної групи з питань
інноваційного розвитку Управління
науки та інновацій Міністерства
освіти і науки України
Національний координатор курсу Анджела
Джексон співзасновник керуючий директор GP
у Portland City fund tiger 21 Portland
share виконавчий директор промисловості та
підприємництва  у залученні в
Університеті штату Портленд бізнес-
урок
ну Експерти з охорони здоров’я, які
сьогодні оцінюватимуть стартапи, ви вирішите, має прийти
керуючий директор qpd digital, але
оскільки це прийде генеральний директор
Директорату високотехнологічної медичної
допомоги та інновацій МОЗ
України  і наші експерти з
сільського господарства та біотехнологій dimitro
механічний Заступник начальника відділу оцифрування
державної в’язниці caduster і andazing
Troop керуючий партнер таким чином Ventures, а
тепер давайте познайомимося з командами стартапів у сфері
охорони здоров’я Tech Health Care перевірка у нас є
перевірка Я фокус на здоров’ї це отримати
консьєрж anima bacterism  лісові пожежі
Вертикальні косметичні засоби в юані для лікування
шрамів і Хелен Бондс Помічник здоров’я в
Темплі та в сільському господарстві Біотехнологічний трек
у них є продовольча консервація для
обробки насіння Система моніторингу та контролю Power Stock Agrabon
для
технології Інтернету речей так Strauss
Органічне срібло robolab Agro але кричав
прогнозування  три лабораторії та садівник-механік
вау, багато стартапів будуть сьогодні,
і подивіться на їхню
чудову пропозицію, а про час у
Саддама буде п’ять хвилин на
пляж і три хвилини на Q-сесію
з дозволу,
тож давайте подивимося, хто сьогодні стане переможцем
і  зараз маю гроші від подарунка.
Я радий повідомити, що перший
стартап на сьогодні – це
стартап Healthstack, і я б запросив на стенд
перевірити. Будь ласка,
перевірте стартап. Я
добре, я сподіваюся, що він буде з нами в цей
час, тому  наразі запусти
здоров’я, ти мене чуєш,
так, здоров’я на борту, ти мене
чудово чуєш, так, звичайно, ти можеш поділитися своїм
екраном,
хвилю, тому що час був трохи
пізніше, тому я просто готуюся й гм  давайте
спробуємо, я зараз поділюся своїм екраном,
звичайно, без проблем,
тож ви бачите мій екран, так, я бачу
ваш екран, я чую вас, тому я починаю ваш
час, у вас є п’ять хвилин, і
ви можете почати,
добре, чи знаєте ви, що глобальна
охорона здоров’я  Ринок дійсний у сім з
половиною трильйонів доларів США, тоді як у 2021 році
ринок лікарів оцінювався майже в 33
мільярди доларів США, і очікується, що він
зросте втричі протягом наступних 10 років.
Покупцями даних є фармацевтичні страхові
компанії, дослідники, маркетингові агенції,
новатори, будьмо чесними.  у наш час
будь-кому потрібні дані для ведення бізнесу,
і в певному сенсі все було б весело,
за винятком кількох моментів, по-перше, погані дані,
неструктуровані дані та відсутність
передісторії, по-друге, обмежена кількість
джерел даних, як-от особи, які беруть участь
в опитуваннях і ліцензують тощо, третій, гм,
нестійкий спосіб даних  обмінюватися між
окремими власниками даних і тими, хто
використовує ці дані, щоб покращити стан здоров’я, що
забезпечується. Ми створили децентралізовану програму штучного інтелекту та
медичної бази даних,
яка дозволяє кожній людині на
планеті Земля таємно й анонімно
зберігати персоналізовані дані, керувати ними та монетизувати їх,
так, монетизувати правильно
ми створили банк медичних даних,
у якому людина створює власну цифрову
медичну картку та завантажує
дані про своє здоров’я. покупці. Фармацевтичні дослідники.
Міжнародні бренди можуть отримати доступ
до цих своїх персональних даних, щоб
розробляти нові ліки та кращі
методи лікування або запускати нові товари
або  послуги, постачальники медичних даних
отримують свою плату, а власники даних – ми
з вами отримуємо гонорар. Health
працює як децентралізована програма з
моделлю Marketplace, де користувачі пацієнтів
можуть
включати свої підтверджені медичні записи в
цифрову мережу, вимагати права власності на
свої знеособлені дані та  помістіть це
в блокчейн D Health, де D Health
AI автоматизує підготовку
наборів даних для споживачів даних, у
нас також є власний маркер утиліти
зі своїм Chelsea, кожен може завантажувати та
зберігати свої медичні, які отримують і
розміщують цифрову інформацію та продають свої
персоналізовані дані.  Метою було
створити джерело здоров’я.
Зростання ринку охорони здоров’я
відбувається завдяки загальним тенденціям і
досягненням у профілактичній медицині, аналітиці великих даних
і оцифровці даних,
однак ця оцифровка медичних
даних в Інтернеті одна інфраструктура
залишає цю чутливу та дорогу
дані досить вразливі для етики,
як відслідковувати і довго прогресувати, щоб
продовжити, отже,
гравці ринку відчайдушно потребують, і
шукають альтернативне рішення
здоровий блокчейн забезпечує саме те, що
вимагає ринок безпечна децентралізована
веб-3 екосистема, спеціально створена для
інтеграції
зберігайте та обробляйте великі
набори медичних даних, усі дані в D
Health dap зашифровані та зберігаються в
централізованій мережі. Система відповідає
закону про захист даних gdpr gdpr HIPAA
та
закону про захист даних, щоб гарантувати
унікальність інформації, доданої до користувачів.
Ідентифікатор завжди залишається деперсоналізованим, а
Anonymous ми використовуємо Keepers from childlink
три мільярди блокчейнів промислова
стандартна компанія започаткувала партнерство
з web3 leader polygon і в
інтегровані платежі за допомогою карток Visa та
MasterCard, щоб зробити взаємодію з
цим більш зрозумілою та зручною, а одним із
засновників системи охорони здоров’я є  президент
Національної асоціації кібербезпеки,
тоді як другий засновник є
президентом міжнародного концерну електронної охорони здоров’я,
серед наших громадських радників є
справжні експерти з різних галузей, від
блокчейну до охорони здоров’я, це означає, що ми
розвиваємося відповідно до ринкових
тенденцій і вимагає здоров’я  веб-програма
вже привабила понад 70 000 користувачів
із понад 80 країн, вони зареєструвалися,
створили свій унікальний ідентифікатор здоров’я d і
почали заповнювати його медичними даними,
щоб бути першим, хто зароблятиме
гроші,
монетизуючи персоналізовані дані
та  ціль у галузі охорони здоров’я на 2023 рік —
утвердитися в Інтернеті 3
мкм у глобальній екосистемі акумуляторів як
стандарту блокчейн-мережі зберігання даних
і децентралізованих платежів у
сфері охорони здоров’я, що досягнуто 5, тому настала нова ера
економіки медичних даних без додатків, і
мета охорони здоров’я  щоб дати можливість людям у
всьому світі повернути назад
контроль над своїми медичними даними та,
нарешті, почати отримувати свою
винагороду щоразу, коли використовуються їхні особисті
дані, а також надавати
споживачам даних дійсні набори даних
у стабільний і справедливий спосіб.
з повагою до власників даних, дякую,
велике спасибі, Марина, за вашу
пропозицію, і тепер у нас є три хвилини на
запитання від експертів, будь ласка,
якщо ви хочете поставити запитання,
просто спробуйте свою руку в масштабі
реакції
тож я можу дати вам слово,
ну, Яна, у мене є запитання, я міг би я так,
звичайно, привіт усім, дякую за
вашу презентацію щодо пляжу, і в мене є
одне запитання, чи ви
проаналізували, як цей проект можна інтегрувати
з існуючим станом  баз даних, таких як
здоров’я вуха або здоровий і фактично із
законодавчими нормами щодо
утилізації даних у сфері
охорони здоров’я в Україні,
так, звичайно, серед наших цілей на
2023 рік є запуск е-е-е-е-е-е-е, з
існуючими міфами та клініками.
Фактично, у нас є веб-2 проект
ASCAP, це мережа, така як
Хелсі, що,
я не накопичив більше трьох
мільйонів 20 000 пацієнтів, так що це
просто момент часу, тому
впровадьте інтеграцію між існуючими
промахами  і система, яка вже існує
в веб-екосистемах, тому, оскільки ми є
власниками такої однієї з таких мереж,
скажімо, скеп, веб-екосистема,
це дає нам більше балів, щоб бути на
крок попереду
інших  решта ринку,
тож зробіть ці інтеграції більш
чіткими, і це те, з чим
зараз працюють наші смерті, насправді
добре, дякую,
ви в Європі, ласкаво просимо,
Марина, дякую за вашу
презентацію, дуже хорошу, що можете
сказати  нам про ваших клієнтів чи
вдалося вам обслуговувати, щоб продати
їм деякі набори даних чи ви коли-небудь хотіли,
насправді, зараз ми ведемо
дуже тісні переговори з
кількома компаніями з галузі охорони здоров’я,
такими як Novartis, Джонсон
Джонстон  AstraZeneca та Nova Nordisk, а
також
представники міжнародних брендів,
як-от L'Oreal
[Music],
в обох, я думаю,
головне, що вони шукають, це
ух, ух, кількість
власників даних, скажімо, зараз у нас 70 000  а також
користувачі, що ми можемо продовжувати роботу
з їхніми даними, але щоб бути більш
корисними для споживачів даних, ми маємо
збільшити нашу базу користувачів до 1
мільйона користувачів у всьому світі. Це наша мета
на цей рік, насправді, до кінця
Щоб бути більш репрезентативним
із наборами даних для
споживачів даних, отже, ми просто працюємо над
збільшенням даних у базі даних користувачів
і хм, хм,
як би сказати, ми трохи змінюємо,
як  дані представлені
тому, що для медичних компаній,
наприклад Novartis або Johnson Johnson, вони
дарують певний тип набору даних із
певними полями. Міжнародні бренди, як-от
L'Oreal, їм потрібен зовсім інший
набір даних із зовсім іншим полем, тож
це також
питання, цільове  з цим
працюють наші розробники, а наш штучний інтелект
вчиться готувати різні типи
різних наборів даних, що тільки на
шляху до досягнення мети: збільшити
базу даних користувачів і, нарешті,
задовольнити вимоги наших потенційних
клієнтів за допомогою правильних
даних  набори, які вони шукають,
дякую, чудово,
ще одне запитання, будь ласка, оскільки я знаю, що у
вас є власний токен, і ви залучаєте 1,6
мільйона доларів через Ico,
що ви можете сказати про
динаміку ціни на нього і чому це так?
Факт на Ideo це було 600
000 доларів США, які ми хм хм так
провели хм це не наша
бізнес-модель це було створено просто для того, щоб
ця екосистема
хм працювала швидко і безпечно і хммммммммммммммммммммммммммммммммммммммммммммммммммммммммммммммммм
стимулом для людей
заповнити їхні
ідентифікатори та продовжити
взаємодію з розробником, але це
просто інструмент, як ви знаєте, блог
в екосистемі, щоб зробити
транзакцію швидшою, безпечнішою, простішою, і
це неприємно або це не платіж
доларів, євро чи будь-що інше, тож це
токен, але ми вирішили, що якщо є
особисті, ну, трейдер вірить у
Pro в проекті компанії та
стартапу, чому б не ввести
податок, ну, токен указано на
біржа bidmark прямо зараз,
і головне, що
попит, кількість токенів
обмежена для одного мільярда цілей, і
ми використовуємо,
як складна економіка,
що ми спекулюємо на цьому
активі  ми просто зберігаємо це, і
це більше схоже на інструмент для
учасників для користувачів розробників
і споживачів даних, які купують ці
купують дані за допомогою токенів, щоб
зробити всі
безпечними всі операції та
Не будьте запитань з боку ринку,
що відбувається з даними, і чому
це так тощо, але це також добре,
цей токен має за собою реальний
матеріальний актив, великі дані, тому ми вважаємо, що
це майбутнє криптомережі
3  токен із реальним матеріальним активом,
у нашому випадку це великі медичні
дані, тож ось чому ми
вийшли на біржу, але ми
не ведемо справи з токенами, ми ведемо
справи з вибачте, хлопці, у нас більше немає часу
запитання для відповідей, вибачте, що
заважаю, але ми маємо перейти до
іншого стартапу, дякую, Марина, це був
стартап,
і ми перейдемо до наступного стартапу, який
має бути першим, перевірка запуску, я
чую, привіт,
так, привіт,
гм,
бачите  мій екран
так, ви можете перевірити, будь ласка, якщо ви можете
перейти до іншого слайда
[Музика]
чудово, ви можете почати
так,
привіт усім, дякую, що я
тут, я продовжу говорити про
профілактичну медицину
гм і гм
я презентую наш проект chicai it's
AI  Кероване Хмарним рішенням для
морозива дійсно може виявити захворювання,
тому кожен у всьому світі має свою
особисту історію, і ми хочемо почати з
конкретної людини. Анна,
українська жінка, яка живе в Наміці, живе,
вона більше 10 років жила з
діабетом і, на жаль,  у сільській
місцевості вона не може перевірити свої
очі, і вона пропустить свою хворобу на
дуже ранній стадії, але через війну
її переселили або перемістили до
Трійці, і вона взяла участь у нашому екрані,
який  був там, і ми відкрили
для неї діабетичну вечірку Крістіни, і зараз
вона проходить курс лікування в
Інституті Філатова в Агессе, і ми сподіваємося,
що ми збережемо ваше бачення на
наступне,
довге, довге життя, тож ця
особиста історія показує, що  Проблеми,
які ми вирішуємо, навпаки, це
фактор населення в усьому світі,
другий – це відсутність професіоналів
і людська природа, тому що ми не
йдемо до лікарів, поки не відчуємо
дуже погані симптоми, але хвороба,
постійні зусилля, щоб вилікувати хворобу
проростає через стадію хвороби. Організація
Об’єднаних Націй у своїй ЦРД
поставила ціль до 2030-х років, згідно з якою ми маємо
зменшити принаймні на 30 відсотків
хронічних захворювань, а
минулого року визначила нову ціль для
них, що принаймні 80 відсотків  людей
з діабетом слід діагностувати, поки
лише 50 відсотків людей знають
про свою хворобу, і
рішенням для цього може бути лише масове
обстеження, яке дозволено обстежувати
багатьох людей похилого віку та визначати людей,
які потребують лікування.  правильний час,
і chikai — це рішення для цього. Ми
розробляємо платформу, щоб зробити простий
і доступний скринінг для всіх
у всьому світі в nvp, ми орієнтуємося на
діабетичну вечірку Крістіни, але в нашій
п’ятирічній дорожній карті ми ввійшли лише до 10 найпопулярніших хвороб
для вирішення 2.5  мільярд людей у ​​всьому світі,
люди, які відвідують пункти скринінгу в
будь-якому місці, починаючи від оптичних роздрібних
аптек чи мобільних пунктів скринінгу, як ви
бачите на зображенні,
фотографію може зробити медсестра чи
інший великий медичний персонал, і ви отримаєте
діагноз за таку секунду з  більш
ніж 90-відсоткова точність, чому ми обираємо
діабетичну вечірку Крістіни для MVP,
тому що це величезні соціальні наслідки,
пандемія діабету 21-го століття,
і принаймні один із трьох людей із
діабетом має діабетичну вечірку Христини,
яка розвиває
проблеми із зором і призводить до  сліпота,
тому ми тепер маємо MVP, ми розпочали наші польові
випробування в регіоні каналу, і до
кінця минулого року ми просканували
300 пацієнтів, принаймні 30 відсотків із
них мають діабет, і
пацієнт сказав, що вони не  я не знав про
це раніше, і ми досягли більш ніж
90 відсотків водоліїв у
виявленні захворювань, у нас є багато різних
зацікавлених сторін, але ми зосередимося на
уряді, тому що ми можемо допомогти
уряду зменшити бюджетні облігації на
НІЗ і ми можемо збільшити середню
тривалість здоров’я для  націю, і в нашій
стратегії виходу на ринок ми зараз зосереджуємося на
клініках і лікарях, тому що ми
надаємо їм багато різних
цінностей, як-от інструментів, які допомагають
лікарям поставити правильний і чіткий
діагноз, і ми можемо збільшити кількість
пацієнтів  клініки Віндзор, тож, як я вже сказав,
ми зараз працюємо з клініками та
намагаємось досягти 100 клінік із
передплатою до кінця цього року,
ми не самотні на ринку, у нас
є кілька конкурентів, але ми маємо величезну
конкурентну перевагу, яку ми виділяємо
конкретні симптоми захворювання на iPhone
це фото, щоб зменшити людську помилку
та людський фактор і допомогти лікарям
поставити правильний та цікавий діагноз
це унікальна функція на ринку,
інша наша перевага, ми звертаємося до
10 найпопулярніших захворювань у нашій дорожній карті, щоб іншим
усі хвороби для людей старше 40 років, і
ми хочемо створити платформу, орієнтовану на пацієнтів,
від комплексної платформи
від скринінгу до контролю захворювань, у
нас є сильна команда, Мікі Логан
Ширук, я маю 20-річний досвід
у цьому  і розробка продукту в Telco. Я
щойно закінчив Global Executive MBA в
бізнес-школі Esa, і я є
членом правління Української діабетичної федерації, і у нас
є медичний радник Андре Керролл, який
більше 20 років працює в медичній
Regina і виконує обов’язки в цьому потокі
інститутів  і у нас є наші партнери
Українська діабетична федерація та
Філадельфійський інститут, які допомагають нам
бути сильнішими. Дякую, і я готовий відповісти на
ваше запитання.
Дуже дякую, кар’єра. Ще одне
запитання від чи пам’ятаєте, чи є у вас
запитання, чудовий пляж, чудові ідеї,
дякую  Ви не маєте питань,
дякую, Ксенія, дякую, у
мене є запитання,
так, будь ласка, Анжела, дякую,
гарна презентація, може, ви
трохи поговорите про наступні
необхідні елементи, які вам потрібні, щоб продовжити
цей шлях
— капітальна
команда перевірки, які б не були наступні
кроки
так, для наступних кроків ми бачимо кілька
пілотів за межами України, тому що наразі
ми маємо підтвердження концепції та працюємо в
kvp в Україні, але нам потрібно протестувати
його в різних регіонах, щоб
переконатися, що він працюватиме з
іншими  регіонів і національностей, на
даний момент у нас є перший короткий пілот із
китайською лікарнею лише зі 100
людьми, і ми бачимо, що ми маємо
подібні цифри щодо точності та
виявлення стадії захворювання, як ми бачимо в
регіоні Serenity та інший наступний крок
для  ми офіційні клінічні випробування
з нулем для досягнення Seema
дуже дякую, ще є
запитання, добре,
чудово, я думаю, що ми можемо перейти до
нашого наступного стартапу, дуже дякую, Кіріле,
це була перевірка запуску, я в нашому наступному
стартапі-учаснику, зосередьтеся на цьому,
привіт
[Музика]
так, звичайно, просто спробуй так, ідеально,
ти можеш почати,
добре, чудово, дозволь мені почати, я також хочу
контролювати час,
тож як ти почуваєшся, коли добре чуєш машини,
щось важливе, корисне, але, чесно кажучи,
у цей час це може бути нудним  важко
говорити, не смішно, немає часу на це
дорого чи будь-яке інше виправдання, що, якщо я
скажу вам, що це було б справді смішно,
подивіться на кількість реальних переглядів, щоб
стати знаннями, прийняти здорову
поведінку,
і дозвольте мені представити Focus eat, це
екосистема ANTEC для  люди, які хочуть
подолати переїдання побудувати зв’язок розуму з тілом
і бути здоровими зцілити своє
тіло розум розум і життя за даними
Всесвітньої організації охорони здоров’я кожен четвертий
українець піддається ризику психічного розладу
через повномасштабне вторгнення Росії
і який найпростіший спосіб  щоб почуватися
краще чи зняти стрес, так, це
їсти, на жаль, це не вирішує жодних
емоційних проблем, і кількість розладів харчової поведінки
зростає навіть у людей,
які раніше не мали проблем із
їжею, і білий міг навіть уявити
відчай людей, які раніше мали
сиділи на дієтах або робили кілька спроб
змінити себе щороку лише
п’ять із 100 людей, які почали вести
здоровий спосіб життя Подорож досягають своїх
цілей завдяки тому, що вони намагаються працювати
лише над збалансованим харчуванням, вони пробують усі
можливі дієти, виключають будь-яку
діяльність з перевезення нездорової їжі, і вони  не
досягають своєї мети система різко
зосереджена у неї є власна освітня та
трансформаційна система методології,
заснованої на таких наукових дисциплінах
харчування гаряче харчування інтуїтивно зрозуміле їжа психологія
лайф-коучинг психічний тренінг
харчування проти старіння робота з тілом
виключення LNP лайф-коучинг та багато багато
іншого, що вони пропонують  повноцінна екосистема
для жінок, які мають надмірне дієтичне
мислення брак енергії тіло ганьба
переїдання страх перед їжею, і ми просто допомагаємо
їм відкрити Життя в Україні означає
багато енергетичної мотивації задоволення та
самозадоволення два трильйони доларів
зростання ринку оздоровлення та здоров’я
щороку та  незважаючи на те, що основні
гравці пропонують індивідуальні плани втрати білого,
вони пропагують культуру дієти та
харчуються чистою, навіть якщо це персоналізовано, і
це як внутрішній цикл дієти, і ми
вважаємо, що настав час зростати
щодня, що галузь створює як
водоспад Фліта, який  втомився від
підрахунку калорій і страждань від цього,
і ми, як фокуси, ми готові вловити
їх і перетворити їх, і перший крок
це україномовний ринок, а
другий крок це англомовний ринок
ми аналізуємо понад 2 000 студентських
заявок і створили рішення для
кожну проблему, і дозвольте мені представити
онлайн-курс їжте тріску це як
підхід, заснований на доказах, щоб дати нашому
тілу все, що йому потрібно
друга проблема і друга причина
в цьому як зрозуміти своє тіло і
їсти без підрахунку калорій, навіть якщо ви
хочете схуднути  Зосередьтеся на тому, як
створити здорові стосунки з їжею,
а не вживати їжу, щоб
покращити самопочуття та полегшити тіло, як
створити здорові стосунки з
власним тілом, назавжди створити енергію та
мотивацію. Наша система продажів — це
звичайна система курсів,
вартість кожного курсу
179 доларів і його тривалість становить вісім
тижнів, але кожен курс можна придбати
окремо, і один курс вирішує одну
головну проблему, і тоді ми вважаємо, що
найкращий спосіб – продавати продукти знову
і знову, і наша система продажів має
простий шлях для початку  кожен курс, який ми
створили як короткий курс, триває 10 днів, як ви,
просто можете перевірити, як це працює, і він коштує
15 євро 15, і ми щодня створюємо платний трафік
із мета з YouTube із Google із
Instagram і ми знаємо,
як продовжувати продажі без кінця
стратегія, ми збираємося продавати це
кожного наступного кроку, що з нашою командою, це
я, менеджер проектів, маркетинг і веб-
дизайнер, підтримка клієнтів, і ми
про планування та прогнозування, ми про
автоматизацію маркетингу, ми
про контроль і легальність, ми про
масштабування за допомогою цифрових технологій
інструмент маркетингу ми прагнемо глибоко аналізувати
нашу аудиторію та
вимірювати, як працюють наші продукти ми
прагнемо досягати результатів і
змінювати життя людей, ми прагнемо
створити величезний чистий результат промоутерів і
ми прагнемо веселитися на роботі, на яку ми
віримо  що любов до свого тіла, психічне
здоров’я, здоров’я, зв’язок із їжею є
важливою частиною уваги людей до охорони здоров’я, це
найкращий спосіб досягти цього, повірте
в себе, зосередьтеся на собі, і я
готовий відповісти на ваші запитання,
дякую,
ідеально вчасно  ти пам’ятаєш, що у них
є, так, будь ласка,
Ольга надіслала тобі чудову презентацію, я хочу
використати твій продукт,
може, ти скажеш мені, що ти, що
саме ти знаєш про свого клієнта Я
маю на увазі, які дані з
розвитку клієнта підтверджують вашу гіпотезу?  по-
перше, цей проект — моя
власна історія, і я думаю, що знаю
все про культуру дієти про
емоційне харчування, тому що це була моя
історія, яка почалася 10 років тому. Я багато запитую
про вашу особисту історію, я запитую
про те, що ви знаєте про
внутрішніх клієнтів
перша стіна схожа на
інформацію, яку вони надіслали нам, яку вони надсилають
нашим клієнтам із продажу, і ми маємо деякі, ми
вирішимо це чотири
різні проблеми, і ми збираємося з
платною рекламою для цього, тому ми, в основному, деякі
люди могли б
описати свою проблему, і це
інформація, яку ми маємо на початку,
водночас ми могли б
представити та запропонувати найкращий продукт
для них, але так, загалом, це схоже на
історію Оуена, про що люди говорять
про них,
який розвиток клієнтів ви зробили
які дані ви отримали від свого
клієнта,
вибачте, мабуть, я не зрозумів ваше
запитання, я маю на увазі, я маю на увазі, я думаю, що ви проводите
дослідження щодо розвитку клієнтів ваших клієнтів,
так, і я запитую вас,
який колір ви отримали від своїх
клієнтів, тож в основному  це
головне завдання для нас — знати, яка проблема у
них, і ми просто розділяємо їх на
групи, намагаємося вирішити кожну
проблему. Я вважаю, що
для нашого проекту важливо мати основні дані,
але якщо у вас є приклад  будь-який інший
приклад, який ви можете мені показати, я міг би
просто змінити свою відповідь, вибачте, я, мабуть,
не зрозумів, що взагалі дякую, у нас
є ще одне
запитання від Діани, будь ласка,
так, привіт, дякую всім за вашу
презентацію  Насправді два запитання:
перше,
розкажіть, будь ласка, чим ви відрізняєтесь від
тисяч спеціалістів з харчування
в Instagram і безкоштовних
марафонів, які довели чи ні
довели ефективність для тих, хто
подає заявку на такі курси, а друге, ну,
як про ваш  команда, яку ви
описали, наприклад, ваші поточні позиції
всіх ваших членів, але чи є у вас такі, як
серед усіх жінок у вашій команді, чи
є у вас спеціаліст з харчування чи
психологи чи щось таке,
хто боїться, хто може надати
професійну допомогу психологічна
допомога мотивація для  ті, хто користується
вашим продуктом тощо
добре,
добре, так що, перше запитання,
я не зміг відповісти, це друге
запитання, так, це я, у мене є
багато дипломів про
спеціаліста з питань харчування, як про коучинг, і це схоже на
все  наші знання, які я маю завдяки цій
освіті, а також мій досвід роботи в міському центрі, і що з
кожним
Instagram-марафоном тощо, так, це
програма Instagram, яка працює лише
один тиждень або максимум два тижні, і
це означає, що ми, наші клієнти,
вони дівчата  які брали участь у таких
марафонах, але в них довго не було
успішної історії, тому
вони в основному відмовилися від нездорової їжі
та М, і вони принесли результат лише на
тиждень або два тижні, але якщо ви
закінчили працювати з
гм так, якщо ви  «Просто працюємо над
рівнем харчування, цього недостатньо, тому ми
вважаємо, що нам потрібно
системно вирішити цю проблему, зрозуміло, дякую,
велике спасибі, і останнє запитання
від Ксенії, лише коротке, будь ласка, так,
добре, дякую, добре  під час
презентації ви сказали, що ви тестуєте
свою платформу і маєте певні результати,
хм, я хотів би запитати, хм, ви
оцінили ці результати і, можливо, після
тестування ви
розробите деякі інструменти, і якщо так, які ми
досягаємо інструменти та більше про результати, будь
ласка, можливо  у деякій статистиці
так, ми маємо спочатку, коли хтось
починає наш курс, у нас є 40 запитань
у кожному, ну, наприклад, людям потрібно виміряти
від нуля до 10, що вони
відчувають з цього приводу, і ми маємо такий тест
наприкінці нашої історії,  і так,
наприкінці нашої розповіді ми також намагаємося знати
не просто скільки кілограмів вони втратили
чи щось подібне, а більше, як
ви ставитеся до цього, які ще зміни
відбуваються у вашому житті, тому люди
починають змінювати свою роботу, професію
так що це ніби дійсно змінилося в їхньому
житті, і так, статистичні дані:
85 відсотків людей, яких вони прийшли від
першого уроку до кінця,
і кожна особа, яка зрештою
розповіла нам про результати, не кожна
людина могла сказати, що за секс або вісім
тижнів вони  схуд, я не знаю, скільки
кілограмів, але кожен казав, що
їхнє життя змінилося,
гаразд, дякую, дякую,
велике спасибі, Ольго, а тепер ми можемо
перейти до наступного запуску, і я радий
вітати кота-консьєржа, будь ласка
ти мене чуєш,
гаразд, я думаю, що ми можемо перейти до наступного, це
стартап-тварина
тут,
так, на хвилинку, так,
ти бачиш екран,
впевнений, ти можеш почати,
добре, так що привіт усім, і я
тут, щоб представити вам анімацію  перша
онлайн-служба стеження за очима для швидкої та
точної діагностики психічного здоров’я, тому
ринок величезний і швидко зростає,
оскільки приблизно 1 мільярд людей
у ​​всьому світі зараз страждає від розладів психічного здоров’я, особливо молодь
віком від 12 до 24 років
вразлива до ризику та  проблема
набирає обертів, тому
прийменник while є нейронауковим тестом,
який допомагає людям уникнути розвитку
психічних розладів шляхом спостереження
за допомогою повторного вислуховування тих, хто запитує
та надання персоналізованих
рекомендацій на основі аналізу
реакції та почуттів людей. Наша
місія полягає в тому, щоб аналіз біомаркерів
і  заснований на доказах підхід до
терапії, який ми віримо в зволоження, тому що
це найдоступніші неінвазивні та
високоточні діагностичні інструменти,
доступні
вони є інноваційними, оскільки ми
запроваджуємо технологію відстеження очей у лабораторії
на ваші пристрої з легким
доступом через Інтернет-браузер
разом із використанням  увагу, упереджене
нейронаукове розставання, щоб оцінити ваше
самопочуття, і тут ви можете побачити на
малюнку маркери в книзі
також ми соціально відповідальні та
допомагаємо вразливим групам у профілактиці
та управлінні психічними розладами вони пропонують
безкоштовні послуги для установ і
терапевтів, які працюють з людьми  у потребі
Наприклад, це дозволяє нашим військовим
силам виявляти небажані зміни в
психічному здоров’ї солдата та
відповідним чином керувати ним. Тут ви можете побачити
початковий екран ліворуч і
сторінку результатів.
Ринок програм для психічного здоров’я
зараз оцінюється в 5,2 мільярда доларів,
а  очікується, що у 2030 році досягне 17 мільярдів доларів
із високою позитивною динамікою з точки
зору конкурентів, є більш
персоналізовані та прості у використанні, ніж
стандартні програми для медитації, які ви бачите в
лабораторії, і вони набагато дешевші та
доступніші, ніж онлайн-консультаційні
послуги UC right
наша команда складається з чотирьох основних підрозділів,
які задовольняють усі потреби Animus, а саме
нейробіології, розробки програмного забезпечення,
маркетингу та психології,
вони провели понад 100
клінічних випробувань і 37 звичайних інтерв’ю,
щоб удосконалити наш продукт,
вони запустили тестову кампанію в США, що
призвело до 2700 користувачів
16  з яких зареєстроване фінансування знизилося до
0,6 відсотка користувачів діапазону, вони вважають,
що така низька конверсія може бути
пояснена довірою кредиту до
ринку США. Кампанії, розпочаті в Україні,
жестикулювали 7 500 відвідувачів, 27 відсотків з
яких зареєструвалися, а 10 з них фактично
купили
наш продукт  бізнес-модель складається з двох
монетизованих пакетів зі звичайною та
професійною щомісячною підпискою. Наша
орієнтовна довічна вартість користувача становить
150 з 55 передбачуваною
вартістю залучення клієнтів і 154 мільйонами
доларів, очікуваним сукупним доходом за
три роки, ми просимо вас 500
000 доларів найбільше  курс буде
спрямований на маркетинг, оскільки ми показали, що
транспорт є основною перешкодою
на шляху до ринку США,
так що це все, дякую, і я радий
відповісти на будь-які ваші запитання,
дуже дякую, Генрі, ти пам’ятав,
чи  у вас є будь-яке запитання,
а в мене є одне запитання.
хм наші діагностичні результати прив'язані до
клінічних протоколів хм це хм
наскільки показники відповідають тому, що
прописано в клінічних протоколах
так що за лікування чи догляд
дякую за запитання ну ну
насправді ну ми  використовуємо науково
перевірені методи з
першої точки зору, яку ми використовуємо під час
психологічних методів даних, а саме
опитувальників, які я використовував
психологами та психіатрами для
менеджерів прямо зараз, а з другої
точки зору ми використовуємо
науковий підхід картону, а саме увагу
білка, який  зараз широко досліджено
з тисячами статей у найпопулярніших
журналах рецензування, таких як наука та
природа, крім того, ми проводимо наші
власні клінічні випробування в цій місцевій
лікарні в Києві та перевіряємо наші
результати з фахівцями,
добре, дякую,
велике спасибі, Анжела, ти  Ласкаво просимо, дякую
за презентацію, чи можете ви
прокоментувати
будь-яку практичну інформацію, яку ви
надаєте або плануєте надати в майбутньому,
чи це просто діагностика,
ви маєте на увазі, всередині людини, яка
проводить тест
для користувача, якась інформація чи
виявивши, що вони можуть вживати заходів щодо
запитань,
так, добре,
як я зрозумів, тут ми надали
людині результат звичайних
анкет, тож як
особиста суб’єктивна оцінка себе
та об’єктивні показники
алгоритму стеження за очима, тож ми спочатку побачимо людину
може побачити, наскільки цей курс
сумісний чи ні, а по-друге, ми
використовуємо широку гілку дерева
рекомендацій, які ми надаємо кожній
особі, щоб вони були максимально точними та
суб’єктивними, і ми
говоримо на основі його результатів
упередженість уваги та на основі його
суб’єктивної оцінки, як він робить і що
йому або їй потрібно бути більше, щоб
бути більш здоровим, щоб зменшити свою
тривогу або благословення його або її
депресії, тому ми пропонуємо унікальну
та суб’єктивну рекомендацію, яка
буде  Задовольнити потреби людини
полягає в тому, щоб відповісти на ваше запитання або,
можливо, навести приклад
рекомендацій, які можуть виникнути з
вашої роботи. Гаразд, ну
ще один приклад, коли
людина отримує низькі суб’єктивні оцінки,
і вони просто відчувають, що він каже, що
я  я не тривожуся, зі мною все гаразд,
але за об’єктивною шкалою е-е, з
технологією відстеження очей. Тест показує,
що він помірно тривожний і е-е,
просто каже, що це може бути добре, що ви
не говорите нам, що ви тривожні,
але, можливо, це  Тривога – це свого роду
тягар у вашому житті. Можливо, вам потрібно
щось зробити, щоб її зменшити та бути
більш продуктивним, щасливішим і здоровішим
у своєму житті. Ось кілька
рекомендацій, тому, якщо у вас помірний
тип тривоги, можливо, ми порекомендуємо
у вас якась техніка дихання,
можливо, ми пояснимо вам, чому у вас
ця тривога, тому що людині
поставили додаткові запитання, і ми
почали говорити, що вам потрібно
це зробити, щоб одужати, або якщо вони
зосереджені на високій тривожності,
Людина століття, що ці цілі, які ви досягаєте, є
високими, і вам може знадобитися додаткова
консультація психологів або
психіатрів, і це вигідно для
користувача, оскільки не багато людей
насправді відповідають, на якому вони справжньому етапі,
і таким чином ми показуємо їм
справжні проблеми, які  вони могли мати, або
іншим способом ми показуємо, що
вони в основному в порядку, і, можливо, вони
зайняті своїм джерелом і тим, як я їм
це пояснив.
Ви можете,
привіт,
ви бачите мій екран,
так,
чудово, так, привіт
ще раз, мене звуть Маршалл
Грабадец, я генеральний директор вашого
стартапу Earth, і сьогодні я представляю вам
революційний продукт far UA під назвою Fire analysis
з моделюванням викидів в Україні
обидва є основними екологічними
проблемами, що спричиняють шкоду екосистемам,
вивільняють шкідливі гази та
загрожують нашим життям,
особливо через війну, відсутність
точних і своєчасних даних і пожежі
ускладнюють вирішення
Основні моменти, які необхідно
вирішити для оцінки розвитку витрат на
пожежі та оцінки їх впливу на
якість повітря серед людей.
наше рішення ми пропонуємо унікальний продукт,
який поєднує супутникову інформацію,
передає еволюцію пожежі та
моделювання викидів для аналізу  клапани
пожежі в їхніх вхідних повідомленні про якість повітря,
і люди, які ми проаналізували всю
українську територію, і вони оскверняють
багато вогнищ, і вони також створили
паливну карту по всій Україні, яка є
унікальною і не була зроблена до того, як
ми маємо модель саме того, що  горить
у повітрі Пляж Ліс Поля або
луки надають важливу
інформацію для боротьби з пожежами
так,
ми надаємо повний опис усіх
пожеж розмір час дата супутникові зображення
наша команда проводить це окреме
моделювання кожної пожежі вимірювання вимірювання викидів
усього, що
було випущено під час  пожежа, як-от
окремі питання озонометр знову діоксид
азоту це діоксид сірки
чадний газ обидва пожежі EA є єдиним
проектом, який може оцінити вплив
пожеж на якість повітря та людей з
високою точністю, оскільки ми створили
карту палива, це дає нам перевагу в
ринок, тому що ми пропонуємо
точніші та надійніші дані, ніж наші
конкуренти, які використовують лише супутникові дані.
Розмір ринку для нашого продукту справді
величезний, оскільки існує постійна проблема
в Україні та в усьому світі,
а тепер через війну їх кількість
зросла  багато разів наші дані можуть
допомогти урядовим установам, неурядовим організаціям та іншим
зацікавленим сторонам приймати обґрунтовані рішення щодо
боротьби з пожежами, що має вирішальне значення для
навколишнього середовища та громадської безпеки.
Широкий місяць 2023 року в березні ми
очікуємо завершення перевірки
моделювання пожеж у моєму остаточному аналізі всіх
пожеж з лютого  2022,
звісно, ​​які супутники можуть бачити, і
починає аналіз у реальному часі, у свою чергу, на основі
накопичених даних про пожежу та з
прогнозом погоди, ми починаємо
тренувати нейтральну мережу для прогнозування
поведінки пожежі, а в липні завершуємо push-
сповіщення в мобільних додатках
про пожежу та вуглецевий дим.
запитайте DST плутаючи масштабні
операції та охопіть дику аудиторію, щоб
повірити, що Wildfire UA має
потенціал для реляціоналізації
управління електроенергією в Україні, і ми
шукаємо інвесторів, які поділяють наше бачення.
Наша команда складається з експорту та
моделювання забруднення повітря, екологічних наук
і даних  аналіз і розробники ми маємо
значний послужний список живих
результатів і прагнемо зробити як
дуже рідкісний успішний проект, так і успішний
запуск.
На завершення дякуємо за ваш час
і намір. Ми віримо, що одяг 12-ї сторони
є унікальним безцінним продуктом, який
має потенціал  зробити реальну
зміну в аналізі
моделювання викидів Cloud Square в Україні, ми
раді почути ваші відгуки та відповісти на
будь-які запитання, якщо у вас є,
дякую, дякую,
ви пам’ятаєте, чи
є у вас запитання,
добре, сподіваюся, що питань немає  для
Metro так,
так, Анджела, будь ласка, дякую, дякую
за презентацію, чи можете
ви поговорити про те, хто є фактичним клієнтом
і як би ви розповсюджували продукт
насправді зараз, справжнім клієнтом є
уряд, а це пожежники
та суспільство,
це топ  три, тому що нам потрібно
виявити пожежі, створити певне
сповіщення для суспільства про те, що у вас
погане повітря, що робити, деякі рекомендації,
щоб не відкривати Windows, не намагайтеся
захистити себе, свою
власність, і робіть усе, що
вам каже уряд, тож що б
процес продажу уряду та
протипожежним установам
наразі ми не будемо продавати
уряду, ми дамо це безкоштовно,
тому що в цих поточних обставинах було б
дійсно важко продати щось
прямо зараз в Україні для цієї мети,
але допомогти їм зробити  вплив і мати
більше користі це має бути справді корисним
три, як би ви розповсюдили інформацію про те, як би
ви розповсюдили фізичний
продукт, як би ви розповсюдили
та просто дізналися про це
в майбутньому, це будуть деякі послуги,
хм, які працюватимуть на  мій API
подобається, тож ідея створити
ліцензування та забезпечити дуже швидке
моделювання цього, тому що для кожної пожежі
в реальному часі ми можемо обчислити це за
годину, і ми хочемо обчислити це за п’ять
хвилин
через брак ресурсів машини
помилки
але з більшою кількістю серверів ми точно можемо
модулювати це дуже
швидко,
дякую, у нас є ще одне
запитання від Ксенії, дякую за вашу
презентацію, моя допомога, швидке запитання
щодо
даних, які ви використовуєте, і чи
можете ви пояснити детальніше, які
дані ви використовуєте та  які джерела та чи
всі ці джерела відкриті чи, можливо, у
вас є тісні партнерські стосунки з
деякими джерелами даних, які ви можете використовувати на
своїй платформі, е-е,
наразі все це абсолютно безкоштовно,
тому що ми використовуємо супутникові дані, як і
фірми NASA, але не лише їх ми використовуємо  фактично
всі супутники, які можуть з’ясувати
реальну ситуацію на землі, що означає
пожежі, тому це загрожує, це щось зараз, це
група різних
супутників, вони абсолютно вільні,
але найважливіше, що ми зробили, у нас
є шар паливної карти, і ми  мати
іншу модуляцію,
що є, що добре, у нас є така точка, як е-е,
сповіщення GPS про позиціонування, де
ця пожежа, у нас є додаткові фотографії,
ми можемо визначити розмір, ми можемо змоделювати
сторону, ми можемо зрозуміти, що там, е-е,
ми можемо змоделювати це, і у нас є інше
передбачення ми знаємо, де цей пил,
де цей дим буде кожні
15 хвилин,
ми можемо створити систему, і ми хочемо
створити систему сповіщення людей
про це, тому почали з невеликого
пошуку, знайдіть пожежі, і нам потрібно
повідомити людей за п’ять хвилин  це
наша мета,
добре, здається, це одна година,
добре, дякую,
велике спасибі, і ми
переходимо до наступного запуску,
я збираюся запросити стартап-помічника здоров’я,
все прямо внизу, ви можете поділитися своїм
екраном,
так,
приємно познайомитися з вами,
бачите  моя презентація так, звичайно,
ви можете почати, це повноекранний режим
так, так girls helper – це стартап у галузі охорони здоров’я та
медичних технологій, який пропонує
мобільний доступний неінвазивний і
точний діагностичний пристрій, який допоможе
зменшити передчасну смертність від серцево-судинних захворювань
на одне дерево до 2030 року
здоров’я  Команда помічників стартапів
представлена ​​balustamus estio it's me
it eager snow as a shift management and
CTO Johannes
and Orlando
who have a high level of Guardian
software software for успішна
розробка та просування Health
Helpel device на ринок, але також їм
потрібен його досвід у проекті
управління та вирішення проблем. Англійська мова
добре підтверджена в RND, і
тому Столлер має досвід
маркетингу, продажів і мереж,
має досвід у сфері бачення, стратегії, кризового
менеджменту, фінансів, внутрішньої аналітики,
вся команда має досвід
спільної роботи понад три роки над
різними проектами, зокрема  основа
урагану Політехнічний університет
ну їхня ідея головна ідея Health
[Music]
вибачте головна ідея
стартап-проекту Health helper полягає у впровадженні
інноваційного та доступного рішення в
практику прогнозних
досліджень здоров’я, що допоможе зменшити передчасну
смертність від серцево-судинних захворювань
забезпечуючи простий і доступний спосіб
ранньої діагностики вірусних захворювань
серцево-судинної системи
рішення - це рішення, надане домашнім
помічником - це неінвазивна і
економічно ефективна діагностична технологія,
яка допомагає в ранньому виявленні волосся
і судинних захворювань, підтверджуючи точну
медичну інформацію  для медичних
працівників технологія розроблена
для вирішення основних проблем зі здоров’ям,
таких як кровообіг,
наприклад, несвоєчасна та регулярна діагностика,
доступність діагностики для більшості
людей, дорожнеча, незручності, страхи
та стрес, а методи вимірювання
наявних пристроїв є неточними, ми говоримо
про мобільний  пристрої, які представлені
на ринку, такі як сучасні годинники,
фітнес-браслети та інші, безумовно,
стаціонарні пристрої, не такі точні,
дуже дорогі, і більшість людей,
особливо за містом, не допомагають отримати
доступ до них,
давайте поговоримо про виконання, ми
вже розвинули своє здоров’я  допоміжні
технології та планує продавати свої різні
канали продажів, націлені на різні
ринки різні цінові точки
нова компанія має модель доходу
000 пристроїв у перший рік, потім
один мільйон пристроїв у другий
рік і п’ять мільйонів пристроїв у
наступні два роки скальпери через  який
планує продавати свою продукцію через
партнерство та угоду з лікарнями
та клініками щодо забезпечення пристроями для
двох пенсіонерів, які потім можуть викупити
їх для особистого користування. наш стартап-
проект відповідає критеріям економічного
впливу, соціального впливу та небезпечної
моделі насильства.
значний економічний
вплив, оскільки він вирішив критичну
проблему в галузі Costco, що може
призвести до кращих результатів для здоров’я
пацієнтів, стартап-проект також має
сильний соціальний вплив на час, щоб
зменшити передчасну смертність на одне лікування
до двадцятих років, підтвердивши
доступність і  неінвазивний і точний
діагностичний пристрій,
так
[Музика]
Стартап-проект Health Helper — це
багатообіцяюча та потенційно
рятівна діагностична технологія, яка має
суттєвий вплив на
індустрію охорони здоров’я.
Враження
добре, я сподіваюся, що все зрозуміло,
дуже дякую, Пабло, а тепер наша наступна
початкова установка в Темплі, ласкаво просимо,
я бачиш мене, ти мене чуєш, так,
звичайно,
тоді я покажу свій екран, будь ласка,
чи можеш ти припинити показ екрана, тому що
Я бачу твій Telegram,
Пабло, будь ласка, припини показувати свій екран,
добре, тепер зрозуміло, дякую, Олена,
я бачу твій екран, добре,
дякую, привіт усім, мене
звуть
Храм, рибний магазин, музична гра для вашого
благополуччя,
ви коли-небудь відчували стрес  у
великому багатолюдному місті внаслідок напруженого
життєвого етапу чи складних життєвих
обставин цей вид стресу часто
призводить до того, що люди відрізняються, і один
громадянин починає відчувати
напад паніки. Я придумав ідею
тактильного чохла для телефону  і додаток, щоб
відволіктися і використовувати від сили,
і ми зосереджені на чомусь більш
приємному в музиці,
насправді ніхто не застрахований від сили
проблема загрози також включає
загальне стигматизацію теми під
іншим ключем з побічними ефектами та
гіпотезою для терапії, яку ми  запропонувати вам у
Temple цифрову музичну гру програму та
чохол для телефону, які використовують численні людські
органи чуття тактильне аудіо та візуальне
впровадження
Результати виявили, що музика, яку ви
любите, може синхронізуватися з вашим мозком
і впливати на зміну частоти дихання
та серцебиття залежно від
темпу  музика
та чому насправді постукування
кінчиками пальців людини є, мабуть,
найчутливішою ділянкою шкіри у тваринному світі
та посилює ритмічну
реакцію людини, яка пов’язана з мигдалиною
та руховим центром мозку, тому давайте
коротко розповімо про гру, яку
людина слухає.  її улюблена музика
або музика, яка має емоційний зміст і
Довіра, повторення є відображенням ритму
або на екрані телефону, або на
футлярі телефону в цей час програма показує
та відображає, наскільки успішно це
вийшло, і, отже, увагу від стресу, загальне
розслаблення
близько 800 мільйонів  люди зараз живуть
із захворюванням психічного здоров’я, і
близько 25 відсотків мають справу з психічним
здоров’ям. Додатки в Temple можуть бути націлені на
40 мільйонів людей, якщо 30 відсотків молодих
людей використовують програми для заспокоєння
серед фізичних об’єктів, спрямованих на
обговорення проблем психічного здоров’я на
загроза вибір для Dimension The Rock from
Earth система медитації даних, але
немає таких пристроїв, як у Тампі
переваги часто Tempo це близькість до
ринку він заснований на дослідженнях він
зосереджений на музиці та її впливі на
фізіологію та психологію це
сам  -пристрій для догляду, який є прийнятним 24 години на
добу та може розглядатися як універсальний
музичний інструмент для релаксації,
що грає на Temple, враховуючи дві бізнес-
моделі: модель преміум-класу для футляра для
F з платними додатковими функціями
та транзакційну модель для корпусу
USP у  Temple — це додаток і
кейс разом
у Temple був одним із третіх фіналістів
останніх Design Awards 2021 і
Creative Hack Awards 2022 і був
представлений у Японії ми брали участь
у програмі інкубації на основі домашніх завдань
для музичних стартапів Музика працює у 2022 році,
і тільки розум  та інкубаційної програми
ще після запуску демоверсії, де це
дійсно позитивний відгук, і зараз ми
працюємо над другою ітерацією
продукту, і ми готуємося до
виставки в Нью-Йорку,
і ось наші наступні цілі покращена
версія програми та подача заявки на
патент отримання наших перших 300 користувачів сторінки
створення такої самої програми для Android
і налагодження виробництва своїх справ
у Temple – це невелика команда, яка має всі
необхідні навички для
подальшого розвитку проекту, наразі ми
співпрацюємо з експертом із психічного здоров’я,
музичним маркетинговим агентством, музикантом  і
виробнича фабрика в Китаї, і ми
витратили принаймні
100 тисяч, щоб досягти наступних найближчих
етапів. Не особисто доступний
24 7, щоб поговорити про приклад з вами,
тож давайте підтримувати зв’язок щодо нашої державної
бази, і я відкритий для ваших запитань  дякую,
дуже дякую, Селена, ти
запам'ятала, чи є у тебе запитання,
так, перше запитання від Ксенії, будь ласка,
дякую за презентацію, я думаю, що це
цікава ідея, і
питання в тому, чи є
орієнтація на вікову категорію та
чи існує градація
підходів до елементів гри
залежно від віку зареєстрованих
користувачів,
якщо я правильно зрозумів, ви
запитуєте про те, чи залежить це від
віку користувача так, так,
добре,
це  Знову ж таки, як молоді люди
зараз найбільш вразливі до проблем психічного здоров’я, це згідно з
даними і називається це відповідно до
результату, і
гмм, молоді люди більше схожі на професіоналів,
щоб спробувати Томпсона, яка
схожа на гру, але загалом ну  Додаток і
футляр для всіх
добре, дякую,
велике спасибі, і наступне запитання від
Діани, дякую,
я просто хочу пояснити,
наприклад, ви виготовляєте футляри самостійно чи
співпрацюєте з кимось, і якщо
були роки, є виробництво  на
даний момент,
наприклад, це не масове виробництво,
наприклад, у нас є два робочих
прототипи, і зараз ми перебуваємо в
середині розповідей із
китайською виробничою фабрикою,
дякую, добре,
дуже дякую, а тепер наш останній
стартап  в будинку технічне відстеження стартап,
тому що це uticals для лікування
дефіцитних і з кістками ви ласкаво
просимо
Я сподіваюся, що ви можете мене почути
Гаразд, так що
якщо стартапи це не в Інтернеті
ну тепер ми матимемо 15 хвилин перерви, щоб
потримати наш подарунок  не забудьте оцінити
стартапи на треку Health Stack, і
ми повернемося за 15 хвилин до
другої частини треку Beach Agriculture and
build Tech, до зустрічі з
іноземцями,
наш перший учасник на етапі,
стартапи, харчові поради, будь ласка,
так, приємно познайомитися  все, що я ділюся своїм
екраном, не могли б ви сказати мені, е-е,
ви бачите це на дошці так, так, звичайно, так, привіт
усім, мене звуть Мері Янбергс,
і я хотіла б представити вам наш
стартап, що стосується харчування, тобто замовлення їжі за зниженими цінами
Згідно зі статистичними даними Організації Об’єднаних Націй,
372 мільйони тонн продуктів харчування щорічно витрачаються
супермаркетами та закладами харчування,
але їх можна перетворити на
реальні гроші,
тож у чому проблема?
Компанії стикаються з труднощами з
своєчасним продажем усіх продуктів харчування, тому вони
втрачають  потенційний прибуток, тим часом
люди, зацікавлені в економії власного
бюджету, витрачають час на пошук знижок
і хвилюються про те, щоб встигнути
їх отримати, рішенням є мобільний додаток, що стосується продуктів харчування,
який з’єднає компанії зі
споживачами, які шукають знижки,
компанії легко опублікують інформацію про
знижки  невеликий
термін придатності, щоб збільшити свої доходи,
споживачі швидко знайдуть офіс
поблизу в режимі реального часу, що дозволить їм
вирішити замовлення заздалегідь,
сплативши в додатку
гм, також ми створили прототипи нашого
додатка для компаній, які зараз
демонструють  простий процес додавання
знижених пропозицій із невеликим
терміном придатності,
а також після цього ми можемо побачити
додаток для споживачів, який показує
простий процес замовлення, який ми створили.
Так, тут мова йде про
перевірку, яку ми зараз активно шукаємо
ранніх користувачів, і
зараз ми проводимо інтерв’ю з власниками бізнесу,
такими як posi group та Uber Eats Ukraine, які
також є ідеальними партнерами для нас, яких ми
плануємо залучити: малі та середні
заклади харчування, роздрібні торговці,
супермаркети та темні кухні, тоді
ми провели місячні тести серед
Сектор b2c наші люди зацікавлені в
знижках згідно з результатами.
Вісімдесят відсотків респондентів
висловили велике зацікавлення в економії свого
бюджету та стикаються з проблемою втрати
часу на пошук знижок Крім того,
переважна більшість із них не мають
можливості відстежувати та
попередньо  -замовляйте прийменники з невеликим
терміном придатності та зі знижками в режимі
реального часу, тому наше рішення користується високим
попитом у цієї цільової аудиторії.
Розрахунки країн, що знаходяться нижче
ринку, є перспективним і минулим, що розвивається
після українського ринку. Наша мета -
вийти на країни Балтії та
ринки Східної Європи,
хоча у нас є великі конкуренти у
світі, найбільший занадто хороший, щоб йти
з річним доходом майже 74
мільйони доларів,
тому ринок є дійсно перспективним
відповідно до українського ринку
немає прямих конкурентів, тому
заклади харчування супермаркети та  роздрібні торговці
рекламують свої знижки та невеликі
продукти натхнення через
власний маркетинговий канал, який не є
ефективним.
наша бізнес-модель проста, мобільний
додаток платить за споживачів, а
підприємства платитимуть 10 відсотків від
кожної транзакції,
ми збираємося почати тестувати
маркетинг  кампанії та зараз працюємо
над MVP, який буде готовий до
квітня, ми плануємо отримати гранти на запуск
Food Wise в Україні, а потім швидко
розширити Європейський Союз і почати
отримувати реальний прибуток, у нас є повністю
укомплектована команда, що складається з
менеджера з продажу  Спеціаліст із зв’язків із громадськістю, дизайнер
інтерфейсу та серверної частини, розробники у
співпраці з spot on Haven, Олександром
Бланко та Даніелем Коченкою, ми втілимо
наш проект у життя. Ви також можете отримати
інформацію з нашого веб-сайту та
поставити посилання на нього, а тут також мої контактні
дані  хоча й тепер я радий
відповісти на ваші запитання,
дякую, Мері та Мікаела, будь ласка, так, дякую, дякую,
Яна, у мене є
запитання щодо попереднього слайду про
команду, чи можете ви розповісти нам більше про
попередній досвід кожного  інші
члени команди
з точки зору, можливо, знайшлися в іншому
стартапі або працюють у стартапі,
ну, ми всі студенти
Одеського національного політехнічного університету,
у нас є спеціальний курс під назвою «
Стартапи в галузі ІТ», і
насправді ми всі виконали  програма
під назвою «Стартапи в цій галузі» від
школи стартапів Владіма Роговського, можливо, ви
чули про цю людину, він насправді
допоміг нам формалізувати нашу ідею та
втілити її в майбутньому, хотів би почати
над нею працювати, а
тим часом говорити про нас усіх, наших розробників Олександра
Бланова  і Даніель має великий досвід
у їхніх навичках, наприклад, для деяких їхніх
мов програмування, але, за
нашими словами, це також наш перший стартап, але
asmale також є взводом Haven, як і наш
дизайнер також мав чудові курси у своєму
досвіді, і я, і я також
виконали проект  і подібний
курс від Google Garris називається
основами маркетингу Google, тож
насправді навіть за цим, незважаючи на наш
невеликий досвід у цьому, ми
дуже молоді, щоб бути
підприємцями загалом, але насправді
ми маємо всі ці необхідні навички та знання, які  припустимо, щоб
якнайшвидше реалізувати наш проект,
добре, і друге коротке
запитання, яка ваша мотивація
брати участь у сьогоднішньому заході, чого
ви шукаєте,
ну, насправді, що я можу сказати спочатку,
це також чудова можливість бути
тут  і зрозуміти, наскільки
українські стартапи потужні, а також
хочуть стати більш мотивованими
продовжувати працювати над цим, а також
гранти та, можливо, інвестиції в наш
проект також стануть чудовою
можливістю для нас ще
швидше розширюватися, тож це також другий
Чому ми тут сьогодні,
наступного разу просто включіть це у свою
презентацію, щоб уникнути добре, тож чого
ви шукаєте, дякую, добре, я
обов’язково це зроблю,
велике вам спасибі, а тепер запитання від
Сесілії,
дякую за вашу презентацію, я думаю, що
це досить  хороша ідея, але в мене є кілька
запитань, щоб зробити проект більш
цікавим для бізнесу, оскільки ви плануєте
взяти 10 з кожної угоди, я думаю, вам
варто подумати про додаткові послуги,
такі як визначення найкращих
шляхів доставки, якщо ми говоримо про міжнародні
перевізники, які  загалом
подумайте над питанням логістики, можливо,
пакуванням чи чимось іншим, чи
думали ви про Touch RS, щоб додати до
вашої програми, тому що ви сказали про
партнерство з
ubereats, тож докладніше про
це,
а насправді, що ми також плануємо зробити,
наприклад реалізувати  також все, що
стосується деяких упаковок,
все, в що буде
упакована їжа, вироблятимемо саме ми,
це не буде як для переглядів полів для
деяких компаній, це буде саме
з наших власних і наших типів логотипів  лайк про
їжу буде опубліковано на нашому лайку,
якщо я можу якось назвати це об’єднання, це
схоже на пакети, ну, логістику також
можна запровадити, але все, що ми
шукали спочатку, ну, це також
можливо, як самовивіз із магазину
точно і можливість мати таку
логістику, якщо ви також замовляєте в
інших закладах, тож так,
ми працюємо над цим, і логістика
також може бути реалізована добре, дякую,
велике спасибі, Мері,
ти хочеш запустити пораду про їжу, а тепер
давайте рухатися  до наступного проекту запуск
битви зупинися ласкаво просимо
добре привіт мить
традиційний екран
е так
ви можете почати через
брак суміші в цьому будинку адреси
регіон озимі культури
гинуть е відповідно до іншого
симулятора Адміністрація шість тисяч
зірок  озимий ріпак його і дві
тисячі гектарів озимої пшениці
вже загинуло привіт мене звуть Євген я
ЦБД в науковому парку відтворюю
технологічні агрегати що підвищують морозо-
та посухостійкість підвищення в
санітарній картці
до 43 соняшник до 65 58 посіви
були  вивчено, які вирощуються в Україні
та як основний агроклуб
зберігаюча обробка
частин насіннєвого матеріалу що яке мікрохвильове
поле день для обробки насіння на
етапі протравлення що дає
можливість відмовитися від використання
добрив і бізнесів, а
також  перед висівом культур для зберігання,
щоб описати патогени та перевірити колір,
ми будемо піднімати транспортний засіб Syrian arms Florida,
суть запропонованої технології
полягає в тому, що цими мікробами
стимуляція кислотного ядра клітини є
значним збільшенням її внутрішньої
енергії та потенціалу, що відбувається, що  всього
призводить до збільшення в два і чотири рази
об’єму енергії аргументації до трьох
разів і станів кореневої
системи, в тому числі перед зимівлею
посівів підвищує стійкість до вимерзлих сумнівів
скорочує період дозрівання на 10-12 днів
за рахунок підвищення сумнівів і морозостійкості
травень мінімізує  ризик електроенергії для
фермерів і страхової компанії, що бере
характеристику агрегату
час роботи до 16 годин на добу живлення
110 2000 220 вольт продуктивність 400 2000
кілограмів на годину ефект
обробки плюс до чотирьох місяців
тому що для українського ринку 25
uh Розмір нашого ринку до 2030 року становитиме понад
100 мільярдів. Перевага Обсяг глобального ринку
29 2027 із 17 до 41
мільярдів доларів. Uh
Зростання розміру світового страхового ринку до 68 мільярдів до
2030 року обсяг вантажів становить вісім відсотків. Наша головна
цільова група тут полягає в тому, щоб  підтверджуємо
результати наших досліджень у Європі та
США згідно з сучасними стандартами після
отримання цього підтвердження. Ми починаємо
впровадження в сільському господарстві
технологічного житла в усьому світі.
Наша технологія відновлюється, оскільки
методологічне впровадження
міністром усієї аграрної політики Великобританії
вирішить періодичне теологічне дублювання  хвиля Технології в
народному господарстві та технології
мікрохвиль заява Agriculture
Group наш технологічний підрозділ відповідає меті
сталого розвитку
також є позитивний економічний ефект
від підвищення врожайності та зниження
витрат на використання добрив та інститути
визнають нашу команду Валерій програма академік
доктор наук
та  директор Університет Великобританії для
бізнес-директора
дякую,
велике спасибі сьогодні за вашу
презентацію, ви пам’ятаєте, чи є у вас
запитання,
так, у мене є, у мене є кілька
запитань, тож, перше запитання,
скільки прототипів ви зробили на
сьогодні?  ми зробили 10 комерційних
зразків
10 комерційних кіл скільки
коштує виготовлення одного прототипу
дев’ять тисяч вісімсот доларів
за виготовлення однієї технологічної одиниці?
Чи обговорювали ви зі
своїми комерційними клієнтами використання
цих прототипів, про що вони
вам розповідали  використання
так, це працює, або вам потрібно
внести деякі незначні зміни, або так, це працює, у
нас є 58 ну тисяч ну наука
ну вибачте,
якщо ви надасте 58
000 наукових експериментів за цією
технологією та тестову реалізацію
сільського господарства, божевільний  сільське господарство,
і останнє запитання щодо
самої технології, чи є ця компанія, яку ви
згадали, sic LLC власником
патентів
на технологію, чи ця технологія
запатентована в Україні,
так, ця технологія запатентована у Великій Британії,
добре, чи є у вас партнер, який допоможе вам
масштабувати це  IP на європейський ринок чи
спілкувалися ви з кимось
на даний момент, ми не маємо жодних шаблонів,
але ми спілкувалися з багатьма людьми,
і ця оцінка, яку ви
надали, тож від п’ятдесяти тисяч до
ста тисяч доларів, буде
достатньою для вас, щоб отримати IP  захист
в Європі, наприклад,
вперше так, досить
добре, дякую, дякую, велике спасибі, ще є
запитання до адвоката стартапу,
добре, велике спасибі,
а тепер переходьте до наступного учасника
Agro born,
так, вітаю, колеги, просто дайте мені
секунду  Додай мою презентацію, звичайно,
ти бачиш мій екран,
так,
і ти можеш побачити слайди з самого
початку,
так, добре, чудово, без
зайвих слів, давайте почнемо, тому дозвольте мені
представити вам наш проект, який
називається agriban, це  Торговий майданчик
для корейських фермерів на базі
децентралізованої блокчейн-платформи
українського походження, тож що це таке, як я вже
сказав, це агроринок на основі
централізованої платформи українського походження, що
дозволяє будь-якому фермеру продавати
свою продукцію за безкоштовні замовлення, щоб
клієнти могли  організовувати організовувати
такі попередні замовлення з юридичними гарантіями
та з повною прозорістю, отже,
по суті, це новий спосіб встановлення
більш надійних ділових відносин із
гарантованим виконанням контрактних
контрактних зобов’язань, взятих на себе
Парижем, і ключовою ідеєю цього
було створення цифрового  набір інструментів для
українських фермерів, який покращить усі
процеси та зробить їх юридично
прозорими, простими та швидкими, тож як
це працює в основі є
попереднє замовлення це суть того, що ми дізнаємося
це засновано на типовій публічній пропозиції
про  майбутня поставка продуктів він
зберігається в інформаційній платформі на основі блокчейну
та реєструється в
блокчейні, тому ми гарантуємо його
постійне збереження та дратівливість, тож
дозвольте мені розповісти вам про робочий
механізм, отже, наша платформа, наш
Ринок, працює через уже
створений веб-інтерфейс  портал під назвою «
один простір», розроблений
спеціально для обміну
оплатою прав власності на покупки
та електронну комерцію, тож це комплексне
рішення на основі блокчейну, яке
включає смарт-контракти та ескроу-
рахунки, щоб ми могли забезпечити оплату попереднього замовлення
та гарантувати бронювання  за
витрати та продукти, доки кожна сторона не
виконає свої договірні зобов’язання,
і ми вважаємо, що одна з ключових
особливостей полягає в тому, що споживач може
призначати та передавати договірні права
іншим користувачам ринку, так що
щодо юридичних гарантій, ми
базуємося на  кожна транзакція за певним
стандартним комерційним та цивільним договором,
тому вона укладається в захищеному цифровому
середовищі та 100 відповідає
чинному законодавству України та
які платежі, окрім
оплати за фактичні продукти,
платежі здійснюються за розміщення пропозиції
та призначення  ваші права на
контракт,
тож чому ми вирішили втілити цю ідею саме
зараз, оскільки ми віримо, що наш час — це
кардинальні та драматичні зміни, щоб не відставати
від часу, який вам потрібен для впровадження нових,
швидко обробляє нові рішення,
тому що
нові технології дають нам  це те, що
нещодавно здавалося нездійсненним і
складним, тепер стає надзвичайно простим і
легким у створенні, і ми віримо, що
рішенням є цифрові технології, тому що прикладні
Рішення на основі технології блокчейн —
це набір інструментів, які зроблять Ринок
простішим, дешевшим, зручнішим і
справедливішим для кожного учасника, і ми
віримо  що ключовим сектором для розробки
стратегії є
сільське господарство, особливо в Україні, і ми
віримо, що воно відіграватиме життєво важливу роль у
післявоєнній економіці та перегляді
економіки України, тому для яких
фермери та інші торговці, які мають
обмежений оборотний капітал, вимагають
гарантій  продавати продукти
за прийнятними цінами, особливо в
такі непрості часи, але ми також
віримо, що не лише фермери, але й будь-який
місцевий бізнес, який хоче купувати або торгувати
свіжо вирощеними місцевими продуктами, може бути
включений до нашого Ринку, давайте поговоримо,
місцеві супермаркети місцеві  невеликі мережеві
магазини чи будь-які ресторани в цьому районі, тому
потенціал майже необмежений,
тож які очікувані вигоди для
фермерів це швидкий, зручний і
надійний спосіб включення угод щодо
замовлення продуктів, щоб ми
могли знати, скільки їм потрібно  вирощувати і
що вони продадуть це за 100 і це
зменшення збитків через комерційний
ризик для держави більш прозорі
та легші для відстеження податкові надходження від
фермерів і для покупців сільськогосподарської продукції це
простий спосіб готувати та зручний спосіб
пошуку та  розмістіть замовлення на
сільськогосподарську продукцію, і найкраща частина
цього — ми усуваємо всіх
проміжних посередників, тому скорочення часу та
витрат — це виграш для кожної
сторони, тож
дорожня карта, тож, перш за все, ми розробляємо
документ із вимогами до продукції та
працюватимемо над впровадженням  це для
існуючої єдиної космічної екосистеми, тому що це
значно скоротить витрати та
час для нас, тоді ми передамо його
спеціалізованому субпідряднику, який є
корейською юридичною компанією, і над прототипом
працюватиме та буде інтегровано
в один простір, що  це, як я вже сказав,
блокчейн-платформу, тоді ми
повністю її протестуємо та інтегруємо, але лише у веб-
версії, оскільки це потребує часу та
технічної майстерності, і ми додамо нові
послуги та розширимо функціональність,
ми також будемо шукати інвесторів
для фінансування та розвитку розвитку
багатомовний мобільний додаток під назвою
agribon, який є областями пошуку в
Україні, США та Канаді, потім ми
розробимо нові документи вимог до продукту
для мобільного додатка, і це
буде частково базуватися на замовленнях
інвесторів та особливостях певних
географічних причин, а потім запуск
сама програма з регулярним
додаванням нових функцій і
можливостей після публікації, тому це є
частиною нашого бачення, як ви можете бачити
на кінчиках пальців
ви можете замовити ви можете придбати ви можете створити
будь-яке замовлення для будь-якого сільськогосподарського виробництва,
і ми також плануємо після запуску
створити ну інформаційні розділи,
де ми зможемо створити цю ну велику
спільноту фермерів і компаній, які
співпрацюватимуть і
просто придумуватимуть нові рішення та
стратегії разом
як частину нашої  Команда,
нас четверо як представників дослідницького
центру економічних і правових рішень,
це насправді частина того, чому ми подаємо заявку
на цей грант, тому що нам, як я вже сказав,
потрібен субпідрядник для технічної
частини, оскільки
ми працюємо в економічній та  юридичні
рішення, але не технічні, тому
нам потрібен хтось, хто б зробив це, е-е, щоб по
суті запрограмувати це, тож це
також відповідає на питання про нашу
мотивацію
та чому ми тут сьогодні,
добре, велике спасибі, будь ласка,
перше запитання
так, дякую, скажіть нам, що одне запитання
не було в моєму списку, ви насправді сказали мені про
мотивацію, у мене є ще одне запитання,
але
які ваші місцеві та
регіональні конкуренти на ваших цільових ринках так,
дякую за запитання,
гм, я б не хотів, щоб ви знали  звучить
претензійно чи вихваляється, але насправді наш
Marketplace є майже унікальним,
тому що ми намагаємося інтегруватися в
унікальну систему, тому що один простір є
в основному унікальною унікальною інформаційною
платформою, заснованою на блокчейні, і
немає прямих конкурентів, звичайно,
можуть бути деякі програми для  просто продають
або купують, але ми вважаємо, що ми даємо
більше гарантій з точки зору юридичних
зобов’язань, і оскільки ми працюємо з
розумними контрактами, ми завжди базуємо кожну
транзакцію, кожне замовлення на контракті, тому
в основному немає ситуації, коли
хтось ризикує, тому що фермер буде
знати  це добре, я підписав контракт, оскільки
сторона підписала контракт, ми перебуваємо в
юридично зобов’язуючій угоді, і навіть якщо
вони хочуть відмовитися від контракту,
вони повинні продати його або передати
права іншій стороні,
добре, тому я маю лише одне запитання
Залишилося, а це питання, на яке ви можете
відповісти, можливо, так чи ні,
компанії для
сільськогосподарського ринку з
прибутком понад 10 мільйонів євро легше
найняти команду та розробити блокчейн
і перенести свою бізнес-модель на
блокчейн  чи вам простіше
побудувати блокчейн, а потім почати
підписувати користувачів
і відповісти на запитання, повертаючись
до того, чому ми вибираємо інтеграцію в
уже існуючу платформу, тому що у
нас є історія з компанією, тому що
ми
проводили дослідження разом
і  тому що це насправді дуже
дорого побудувати систему блокчейн
з нуля для компанії навіть для
компанії з доходом 10 мільйонів
євро, тому ми намагаємося
інтегрувати, тому що вони вже мають 50
тисяч користувачів з понад 20 країн
і вони ніколи не робили, ви знаєте, і
якесь велике обурення з точки зору маркетингу,
тому вони все ще можуть
розширити
свою базу користувачів, і ми вже
перейдемо до готової платформи та
скоротимо час і витрати на створення  і просто
створити рішення буде,
я б сказав, що це буде безпрограшна
ситуація для більшості з нас. Дякую, дякую,
дуже дякую, ласкаво просимо, дякую
за презентацію та за важливий
проект. У мене є одне запитання.  які
послуги для логістичного підключення
будуть доступні на платформі, і
можливо, це буде можливо укласти
в майбутніх контрактах на доставку на
платформі, оскільки у випадку, коли ми
говоримо про невеликі приватні фірми,
для них дуже важливо мати справу з
партнерами  з вигідною логістикою для
всіх сторін, тому я думаю, що це буде
доречно, тож що ви думаєте про це
так, безумовно, це в планах,
як
гм, я б не сказав, що це
буде в першій веб-версії,
можливо, але гм, як я вже сказав, ми  Будемо
вдосконалювати функціональні можливості та додавати нові
функції, і один із ключових пунктів
нашої дорожньої карти в майбутньому, ну ближче до
цієї програми запуску, можливо,
незабаром після періоду запуску, це буде додавання
послуг, а не лише розміщення
пропозицій для продуктів самих продуктів,
але, можливо, з’явиться якийсь користувач  хто сказав, що
добре, я можу передати це від фермера
до клієнта, тому ми також
запровадимо ту саму стратегію, яку вони
укладуть на законних підставах, забезпечивши
угоду, в основному, контракт на
платформі, він зберігатиметься в блокчейні,
тому це незмінно, це завжди
прозоро для всіх  бачу це так, що так, щоб
дати вам коротку відповідь відповідь, звичайно,
е-е, тому що ми намагаємося
робити це не лише про продукти, але й про
послуги, тому створюємо цю гігантську
сільськогосподарську спільноту на
ринку, тому я не про продукти, а про
послуги,
добре, дякую  так багато для нас
це був стартап agrobon, і ми перейшли до
наступного стартапу так, прогулянки тут
так, привіт, я тут, хм,
мені потрібно поділитися екраном, так, так,
Роуз,
ми виробник біорозкладаної продукції,
і ти можеш переглянути мою презентацію
так, звичайно, ідеально, тому компанія так,
Роуз, ми були засновані три роки тому
мною та моїм співзасновником, і
гм, ми є виробником
біорозкладних і
екологічно чистих соломинок для пиття, зроблених
з е-е-е-е-е, Кейн — це
рослина, це відомо більшості  про нас, як ми читаємо,
воно існує майже в будь-якій країні
Європи на водних шляхах, озерах і
річках, тому наш поточний продукт дуже
простий, це просто трубочки для пиття, зроблені
з великого стебла, ми розробили нашу
власну технологію для обробки
цієї землі в продукт, який не
стартап або ідеї на ринку,
компанії три роки, тому наразі
ми продаємось в Україні,
Нідерландах, Денвері та Іспанії, у Португалії, в
Польщі та Чехії, в Ізраїлі,
в Об’єднаних Арабських Еміратах, ми встановили
дуже хороші зв’язки з місцевими та
міжнародними
дистриб’юторами, тому для  наприклад, ось, будь
ласка, список наших
клієнтів в Україні, ось список
наших клієнтів
і дистриб’юторів в Україні, тож ми
представлені у дуже великих національних
мережах роздрібної торгівлі та зростаючих
спеціалізованих роздрібних групах, тому ми маємо
міжнародне
виконання як приватні  етикетка, яка є
основою нашого бізнесу, тому більшість
наших продуктів представлені іменами
наших клієнтів, тож якщо ви побачите е-е-е, читайте
Strokes будь-де в Європі, це,
мабуть, ми, але лише ми, але не США, я
маю на увазі, як ми, але там  не порушував
іншу компанію, тому ми
вже маємо зареєстровану інтелектуальну власність
і сертифікацію, і справа в тому, що
наразі ми не в такому хорошому
фінансовому стані, але нам потрібно
часто переглядати нашу сертифікацію, тому
ми подали заявку на вашу програму.  ми
можемо поновити нашу сертифікацію для
європейських експортерів, тому що наші
поточні сертифікати видані
майже так, три роки тому на
початку нашого бізнесу, і тепер ми
хочемо зробити те саме, але в Європі ми
хочемо робити це з європейською лабораторією
з європейським регулятором  підтримка
перерахованих тут правил, тому трохи
про вибачення, тому технологія
більше схожа на обробку, ніж на виробництво, тому
ми працюємо з
тим, що збираємо з водних шляхів, і
ми обробляємо це за допомогою нашої
власної технології, наш поточний
випуск
хм, три мільйони штук на місяць, але
з тих пір, як почалася війна, у нас мало,
хм,
я думаю, більше 10 штук, тому
це вже не так, як раніше, але загалом у
нас все ще є дуже добре, хм,
ми все ще  маємо дуже хороші зв’язки з
нашими клієнтами як у школі, так і за кордоном,
і ми хочемо
повернутись на правильний шлях, я б сказав, що
цього разу належна сертифікація
дуже допоможе,
велике дякую, так, велике дякую
[Музика]
два запитання, насправді,
перше запитання, яке ви згадали,
що зараз використовується щонайбільше 10 ємностей,
тож із 28,8 мільйонів соломинок на рік
у вас залишилося 2 мільйони соломинок на
рік, три мільйони, вибачте, чому це
так, як ви згадали, через війну,
але  у чому саме полягає проблема, це
проблема із сировиною, це проблема в
енергопостачанні чи з робочою силою,
точніше, у чому проблема, так, це
дуже розумне запитання,
дякую, так що поки що основна
проблема, з якою ми зіткнулися
нижчі продажі, тому в нашій структурі
продажів ми були приблизно 50 50. Таким чином, 50
було для українського ринку, а 50 для
експорту Тож наразі наші місцеві продажі зменшилися,
будь ласка, зателефонуйте, і наші експертні продажі
вдвічі зросли з тих пір, тому ми зіткнулися з деякими
проблемами зараз це  стає краще, я б
сказав, що зараз буду використовувати Дистриб’ютори
повертаються до нас і планують нові
замовлення, але з розповсюдженням це
не так, як ви знаєте, що вони приходять сьогодні й
замовляють, а наступного тижня, де
доставка є проблемою, він планує, він
завжди планує  півроку вперед
за вісім місяців вперед, тому будь-які
переговори, які відбуваються сьогодні,
матеріалізуються як замовлення для
нашого виробничого підприємства, тут не кава,
отже, минулого року ми застрягли,
бо ви знаєте, що вони були як
Я б сказав, що інші
дистриб’ютори справді підтримали та
допомогли нам особисто, особливо з моїм
партнером, вони пішли в арбітр Force, тому
вони дійсно допомагають нам навіть зібрати
щось на обладнання для дронів і
генераторів для його підрозділу, але з точки зору
ділової активності кожен
Чужа система,
я бачу, що це не проблема з ємністю, це не проблема з
вашого боку, а
набагато більше проблема з
вашими підрядниками, так, хто купує у
вас, добре, тоді друга річ, як я
розумію, ви були на ринку
протягом трьох років ви
виробляли 30 мільйонів соломинок на рік,
бо протягом усіх цих трьох років, скажімо, в
середньому, е-е,
технологія, яку ми почали ми насправді ми
починали як торговельний посередник, ми купували
соломки у дитини Китайські
виробники виготовляли не з читання, а
з  на іншому заводі, і коли ми
почали, оскільки наші продажі почали зростати, ми
вирішили, що нам слід виробляти цей
продукт за новий кредит, тому ми почали з
невеликого пілотного виробництва, яке
виробляло приблизно 100 штук на місяць,
а потім ми перейшли на наступний рівень, який
був як  100 і тисяча, добре,
скільки грошей ви вклали
у виробництво
[Музика]
і скільки грошей вам потрібно
принаймні, щоб розпочати той самий процес у
найближчих країнах,
тож поки що наші основні інвестиції будуть спрямовані
на перезапуск  як бізнес, який ви
знаєте, у масштабуванні діяльності, тому цей
курс ремаркетингу це буде
придбання сировини поштою, це
буде вартість ем,
витрати оборотного капіталу так, так,
саме так, це не так, це
не зовсім хімічні витрати, тому що це
вже зроблено, ви знаєте, і  наша історія
насправді дуже довга, ви знаєте, що ми
пережили велику пожежу, ви знаєте, що наше
поточне виробниче підприємство є
другою версією нашого виробництва,
тому що ми маємо першу
деякий час тому в іншому місці, тож
була стаття про бізнес, ну
про наш  недавно, де
ми розповідаємо історію, як ми прийшли так далеко, ви
знаєте, що це було в корпорації протягом двох років,
і для нашого бізнесу це було як е-е, ви
знаєте, наші основні клієнти згідно з
дистриб’юторами людьми, які покладаються на
ресторани, бари та готелі для їхнього
обсягу продажів  так, і коли
еквівалент був великою економією, ви знаєте, що
це вже не так, але в ті дні, е-е, ми
ніби
пішли на нуль, наші великі продажі до covet
становили близько 1 мільйона засобів для чищення на місяць,
і ми пішли на нуль за один місяць, що
було схоже на великий успіх  але ми вже
вижили, тоді ти знаєш, що ми пройшли, і
ти знаєш, що це було важко, але ти це зробив, я
думаю, у Оксани теж є запитання, я
не знаю,
дякую за відповіді, дуже дякую,
добре, у мене є коротке запитання і дякую
ви для презентації,
хм, використання технології та упаковки Echo
є дуже необхідним і справжнім
напрямком, але на ринку вже є досить
багато аналогів. Я, я думаю,
ви знаєте компанії, які виробляють ті самі
продукти, але з інших матеріалів Echo,
ну, на вашу думку  у чому полягає
унікальність вашої ідеї та чому
потенційні клієнти повинні обрати ваш продукт
? два слова про сам продукт, тому
початковість прогулянок,
виготовлених із породи, набагато вища, ніж у
будь-якого конкурента, я маю на увазі, як паперові соломки,
соломки, виготовлені з пшеничної соломки, виготовленої з
будь-який інший композитний матеріал не
підходить з точки зору міцності, тому наші
соломинки можуть бути у воді та пити
вісім годин або 10 годин, не
втрачаючи форми чи характеристик, тому
це дуже добре для обговорення якості,
це стосується продукту,  знаєте,
чому це краще, просто ви знаєте
кращі якості, ніж будь-які інші види
конкурентної проблеми з ділової
сторони речей, е-е,
обсяг соломинок для напоїв, які є
зараз у чомусь у світі, настільки величезний,
що будь-який, давайте називати його так не
конкурентами, а е-м  Альтернативи
пластику в поєднанні вони не можуть задовольнити навіть
п’яти відсотків потреби в
чомусь, тому на
цьому ринку є простір для всіх для паперових
соломинок, соломинок із зелені чи
соломинок із міцного бамбука для
прогулянок із кавових зерен  або соломинки
з авокадо,
хм, почуття, які ви знаєте для всіх,
щойно це відбувається, ви вже
знаєте, що Європейський Союз над Японією, е-е,
пластикові соломинки, і наступні п’ять-чотири
роки будуть періодом, коли вони
просто продають запаси, але не поповнюють
їх  Так, Європейські комісії
заборонили вам
збирати магазини, але
дистриб’юторам дозволено продавати існуючі запаси,
навіть якщо це погано, але це вже
важливо для вступу в Європейський
Союз, тож вибачте, що перебили вас,
у нас більше немає часу на Q  сеанс,
дуже дякую, ми маємо перейти до
наступного стартапу, дякую, наступний старт,
це теогенне срібло, я чую,
дуже дякую за нашу
можливість представити мій стартап
лише одну секунду, завжди знову тут, і
ви бачите все, гм,
так, зараз усе гаразд  ви можете
розпочати, дякую, ну, я дуже радий
представити вам свій стартап biogenic
nanosal,
поки ми фактично обираємо головну
ідею біогенного ні, срібла, тому що воно
має високу ймовірність безпечності та
бактеріального побічного ефекту,
яка наша головна проблема  за два дні,
перш за все, згідно з містами
наночастинок, існує хімічний синтез,
це дорогий процес, також поєднання
токсичних стабілізаторів і високої
температури синтезу в іншій частковій проблемі, у нас
є проблеми, що бактерії
стійкі до лікування антибіотиками,
тож що мають наші конкуренти відповідно до
продукти зі срібла вони мають
колоїдну форму срібла, ми хочемо використовувати
біогенні наночастинки срібла,
тому наші рішення виглядають так, що
в біогенному синтезі використовуються дешеві субстрати.
Наночастинки срібла можна
стабілізувати за допомогою лізиду з
Сакраменто, а бактерицидну дію
також наночастинки, які не викликають
розвиток бактерій  опір давайте
коротко подивимося на це слово
аналіз сильні сторони нашого проекту
дешеві прості та ефективні ліки які
можливості нам потрібні для оновлення
сучасного обладнання та власне обладнання
для розширення крок як слабка сторона як
слабкий інвестор підтримує та серія
High Market  конкуренція, як завжди у
фармацевтиці,
давайте подивимося на огляд продукту три основні
моменти нашого продукту, по-перше, ми
використовуємо срібло срібло, це чудовий
бактерицидний засіб, по-друге, я вважаю
нанорозмірну ефективну дію та
вразливість, а також частину, яка
стосується безпеки та почервоніння навколишнього середовища.
як щодо аналізу конкурентів:
якщо ми бачимо препарати, які ви
отримали срібло, ми бачимо, що ширший спектр
препаратів із вченим Дель Сільвером
був у 2018 році
22. тепер у нас менше різних
речей із сріблом, а також ми бачимо,
що сьогодні це  збільшення
процесу для препаратів зі склероделем срібло
також конкуренти зазвичай використовують
срібло для дерев Дороги та вузли катастрофи,
але ми хочемо
додати наші препарати для
лікування шкірних захворювань
годину срібло можна використовувати у зручній
формі гелю або спрею та не спричиняє
стійкість до бактеріального циклу  і не
забруднює навколишнє середовище. Колоїдне срібло,
яке ми насправді можемо знайти, зараз є у фармацевтиці.
Зазвичай використовують креми чи мазі.
Принаймні відчуття жирності. Також
не викликає резистентності бактерій, але має
деякі обмеження щодо концентрацій.
Антибіотики, як найконкурентніші
речі.  для нас довготривала абсорамічна мазь
зазвичай використовується неефективна проти
ланцюгів резистентності бактерій і
може діяти як забруднювач як
середовище, яке реалізується в
штамах логіки резистентності. Наша мета —
виробляти такий продукт, який має
середню ціну для клієнта. 100 бігунів
також ми хочемо розвивати  наш
продукт у формі спрею або гелю,
заснований саме на біогенних
наночастинках срібла, коли ми дивимося на
споживачів за віком, це будуть
дорослі люди, які можуть зрозуміти цю
проблему та безпеку нашого продукту,
а також літні люди, які вже мають
проблема з резистентними захворюваннями,
що було зроблено на даний момент, на
даний момент ми маємо технологію, яку ми
розробили технологію для отримання
біогенних наночастинок срібла, отже, використовуючи
гм
ящірку або так, також ми знаємо
фізичні характеристики розмір
наночастинок і можливість
їх регулювання на  етап
речень також описано, і ми вже
знаємо біологічну дію, яку ми аналізуємо,
що наші наночастинки ефективні проти
стафілокока Oreos або миші або обличчя,
що потрібно Необхідна гарантія
збільшення продажів для клінічних досліджень доказ
безпеки ліків клінічні дослідження доказ
ефективності ліків  а також
тестування готового продукту спрей Angel
form
um Інвестиції, які вимагали
більшої частини, полягали в інвестиціях, які нам потрібні
для обладнання точно до масштабу,
а також у зарплаті та маркетингових
дослідженнях, тому що ми все ще не знаємо,
як чітко вирішити
наш продукт там ви  подивіться нашу команду
нашої команди це професіонал з
біології та біотехнології,
дякую за увагу,
велике спасибі, Михайло, будь ласка,
так, дякую за презентацію, Ольга,
у мене є два запитання, перше
питання щодо фінансування, чи можете ви обмінятися
до слайду фінансування
так, так, цей цей цей цей, будь ласка,
залиште його, щоб я правильно зрозумів, це
2,5 мільйона або
як я повинен ні ні ні ні це
згідно з тими висновками, які ми можемо
знайти в ці персикові дні, тому що
ви  знаю, що я не маю можливості,
скільки саме п’ять місяців нам потрібно,
щоб забезпечити біотехнологію, яка називається
фармацевтичним продуктом, виберіть кінцевий
продукт, е-е, просто дві
тисячі ціла п’ять сотень,
добре, ви ще нічого не запланували
в масштабі, скажімо так  це
інвестиція так
доступна так добре
добре на даний момент ми маємо
лише експериментальні дані так я знаю я
розумію чи ви розумієте
різницю між компанією r d uh
та фактичною діяльністю з продажу та маркетингу
у фармацевтичній промисловості
як це працює що  ролі
різних типів компаній, так, я
розумію, і саме тому
метафічний біотехнологічний
продукт дуже низький у нашій країні, оскільки
саме ця проблема, коли ми
говоримо про біотехнологічний
продукт, ми повинні розуміти, що
це не про  вирішення деяких фізичних
проблем або проблем зі здоров’ям, перш за все, це
стосується заробітку, тому, якщо ви хочете
продати свій біофармацевтичний продукт,
ви повинні точно знати
час, коли ви нарешті зможете
повернути гроші, а також вам потрібно
зрозуміти, як  багато часу та людей, яких вам потрібно
використати, щоб зробити ваш продукт справді
придатним для продажу,
добре, але після виступу, будь ласка, перегляньте
різницю між
компаніями, орієнтованими на науково-технічну діяльність, і компаніями, орієнтованими на маркетинг і продажі,
добре, просто
коментар, друге запитання, що
я хочу запитати  про команду та
власне про те, що ми робимо, у вас є
зареєстрована компанія, або ви просто
науковці, амбітні вчені в
дослідницькій установі, які хочуть
комерціалізувати свою, скажімо, докторську
дисертацію чи щось подібне, щоб я міг
чітко зрозуміти, це  у
другій частині ми як група вчених,
і насправді це наша робота, над
якою ми працювали кілька років,
і ми просто мотивовані знайти
для нашого продукту наші рекламні ролики. Я сприймаю
добре, дякую, дякую,
дуже дякую,  ти пам’ятаєш, чи
є у тебе ще запитання,
добре, дякую, Ольга, дякую,
і ми перейдемо до наступного стартапу
startup robot Agro, будь ласка,
я просто бачу ваш робочий стіл, а тепер ваша
презентація,
добре, вітаю, мене звати
Герберт, я представляю робота  Агро
стартап поле робототехнічний мобільний вишивальний
комплекс персональна збірка Україна є
аграрною країною за
статистичними даними у 1811 році
в Україні було 70 803 сільськогосподарських підприємств
із цих трьох тисяч і посилань
вирощують зернові та
зернобобові культури на площі
понад тисячу гектарів
сільськогосподарська форма  продовольча економічна
екологічна та енергетична безпека забезпечує
розвиток технологічних суміжних галузей
соціально-економічні засади
розвитку сільських територій в
Україні сільськогосподарські сектори
забезпечують у середньому 10 відсотків
ВВПМ та близько 40 відсотків паспортних
площ одночасно у зв’язку
з  Росія виграла проти України та
п’ять мільйонів факторів сільськогосподарських
угідь або 50 осіб змінної та в
Україні є моїми,
що унеможливлює вивезення
людей на роботу в зону бойових дій. Така
ж кількість територій може бути під загрозою
мінування або існуючих
передових технологій.  і нові квартирні
методи пропонують новий підхід до
сільськогосподарського виробництва це вплив на
навколишнє середовище від безпілотних літальних апаратів і
супутників до iot і типові
інтелектуальні технологічні інновації є
формування Департаменту Промисловість і
глобальний розумний публічний ринок
неухильно зростає протягом останніх кількох років
і  прогнозується, що в поточні роки зростатиме ще швидше
розмір ринку квадронів у розумних
насосах ви збільшите до 4,8 мільярдів
доларів США до 2024 року сільське господарство Інтернет
речей у Європі, за винятком того, що
очікується зростання з приблизно 1
мільярда важливих до 2 мільярдів
доларів США  до 2021 року
для підвищення врожайності сільськогосподарських культур сучасне
землеробство Технології питання систематично вносяться мінеральні
та органічні добрива
перед удобренням
необхідно провести
агрохімічні дослідження з підбором
підстав для проведення СНІДу та голосів
без встановлених ушкоджень схрестити
це важко зробити  це за допомогою
важкого обладнання через
неможливість висоти землі –
це роботизований мобільний пристрій про людей, які досліджують
складання ґрунту та моніторинг стану поля в режимі реального часу.
знаходиться на землі контроль
його роботи здійснюється за допомогою та
запускається,
а всі пластикові частини платформи
друкуються на 3D-принтері використання
спеціалізованого програмного забезпечення для керування
роботом освоєно можливість
використання турболабораторії Абрама та
трьох  -вимірна модель була
вражаючою з точки зору
Інновації в агробізнесі є
основою продовольчої безпеки країни,
тоді вимоги та переваги жахливої
лабораторії Абрам – це мобільність і швидкість, а також
зменшення шкоди посівам і її можна
використовувати навесні, коли навесні  попередній
перегляд, коли важка техніка
недоступна, і це безпечно в зонах пам’яті,
головним елементом нашої системи є
апаратне керування польотом пілота, в яке
дозволені викиди через
програму панелі місії,
алгоритм комп’ютерного бачення на Python
із використанням бібліотеки opencv також знаходяться під
розробка
за допомогою засобу перегляду Google Print поєднує в собі
високий інтерес до роботизованих
пристроїв у світі
бізнес-модель стартапу B2B –
онлайн і офлайн продажі сільськогосподарським
підприємствам і агрохімічним
лабораторіям, тепер ви можете побачити в нашій
дорожній карті екрана на екрані, який ми  ми
вже маємо MVP, ми плануємо, якщо банківська система
доступна, щоб покращити його та вивести
продукт на ринок на цьому слайді ви
можете побачити нашу роботу,
це все, дякую за увагу,
дуже дякую, чи
є у вас запитання щодо стартапу,
привіт, ви  Ласкаво просимо, як завжди,
так, я просто хочу зрозуміти ідею,
давайте подивимося, чи
правильно я розумію, що цей
робот полегшує роботу у
важких, скажімо,
вибухово складних умовах, лише
в тих конкретних випадках, чи його можна
використовувати в інших типах ситуацій, де
земля, скажімо так, не є ідеальною для
важкої техніки, і якщо друге
вірно, то чи можете ви навести мені
приклад іншої ситуації, в якій
цього робота можна використовувати
зараз, у нас є на MVP той, який має
всі
функції, але якщо, але в майбутньому  ми розробляємо
прогресивніші стреси для робота, а
також ми працюємо над
розробкою блоку камери, який
допомагає нашому роботу
гм [
Музика]
це буде
гм
допоможіть нашому роботу [
Музика]
не рухатися до перешкод, добре,
добре, я розумію
гаразд, дякую,
старший, ласкаво просимо, дякую
за вашу презентацію та розкажіть
нам про те, в чому полягає унікальність
цієї платформи та які її
переваги порівняно з
аналогами, які ми можемо побачити на ринку.
непрямі пристрої конкурентів, які функціонують як
вершина важкого обладнання, тому наш робот-газ має
значні переваги,
але приклади прямих індикаторів
це, можливо, інші сільськогосподарські роботи,
такі як uh field робот Fox від uh Indigo
та сферичну uh робот-сферу зростання
було створено дослідниками
пошуки або з
Мадридського університету, але скажіть, що ці пристрої можуть
ці пристрої можуть робити лише на ем
так,
ви можете надати лише ем температуру
вологість і кислотність об’єм ґрунту
але наш комплекс може зібрати
зразок ґрунту з Focus
дякую
тобі Анжела ти  Ласкаво просимо за ваше запитання,
дякую за презентацію, чи можете ви
розповісти про будь-які розмови з клієнтами чи
інтерв’ю, які ви мали з реальними
компаніями, що займаються виробництвом яєць, або фермерами, щоб визначити, що
це бажаний і потрібний
продукт,
е-
е, деякі місцеві фермери
були зацікавлені в цій конференції,
добре, дякую  так багато, я думаю, що ми
можемо перейти до наступного запуску, а
наступного запуску це з Yelp для кастингу, будь
ласка,
добре, що це за секунда,
ви бачите мій екран, так, звичайно, можете
почати,
привіт усім, мене звуть Максим, я хотів би
представити  проект під назвою video
for casting
brain production є однією з
найважливіших галузей економіки
України, що забезпечує продовольчі потреби
населення та стабільно в на
поточний момент
середньорічне виробництво зернових
в Україні за 2019 2021 рік досягло
рівня 75 млн.  облігацій, а
середній річний експорт протягом цього часу
становив 50 мільйонів фунтів,
багато
споживання зерна в останні роки
не перевищувало 20 мільйонів фунтів,
це приблизно впевнена особа
всього виробництва зерна, і 70 відсотків
зерна експортується
та Аналіз відео Динаміка в
регіонів України за останні 22
роки показує, що врожайність зростає,
однак тенденція
до збільшення врожайності зерна супроводжується
значними коливаннями врожайності,
перебіг яких здебільшого пов’язаний з
впливом погодних та кліматичних факторів
на роздрібну торгівлю.  на
ілюстрації
величина відхилення від намету
напряму залежить від впливу
кліматичних Фактор головним чином потонув
це показує, що температура
вказує на потребу зробити й початок червня,
а кількість опадів у квітні
вчинити найбільший вплив на врожайність
ми використовуємо їх в інноваційних  підхід,
відповідно до якого тенденція детально описує,
де ви розділені на дві групи
рівень s ми люб’язно поступимося та низький
поступимо
ми використовуємо шість методів для побудови двійкової
моделі класифікації серед перевірених
повідомлень машинного навчання випадкових
методів лісу введіть підтримку Векторне
повідомлення показало найкраще  Модель EQ you see
побудована для степ-зони
України також будується модель
для дітей України нашим головним
результатом є інший проект дають
можливість прогнозувати відео з
горизонтом три місяці модель
побудована за допомогою машинного навчання  методи, що
використовують перехресну перевірку,
тоді було розроблено рішення з двох типів
прогнозування.
Використання машинного навчання заважає всім
вам досягти точності прогнозування для 85 осіб.
Перевага нашого підходу полягає в тому, що
вдосконалена точність прогнозування випадків,
але погоджується на високу продуктивність і
низьку  оцінки врожайності,
оскільки модель прогнозування має
горизонт у три місяці, її можна використовувати
для прийняття рішень у перспективних тенденціях зерна
проект вимагає залучення додаткових
інвестицій у сільськогосподарський
сектор
проект корисний для трейдерів, які
займаються продажем врожаю
реальний світовий прогноз
VTO ці дорогі ціни опосередковано приносять
користь завдяки усним транзакціям
велике дякую
велике дякую ласкаво
просимо за ваше запитання
так дякую за презентацію
Максим у мене є пара запитань ну
так ви згадали, що ви
тренувалися  модель на основі
доступних даних за три місяці, як ви очікуєте, що ця
модель буде працювати, скажімо, рік, якщо
ви розширите набір даних до річних даних,
щоб повні, скажімо, урожаї два повних
цикли врожаю Ви очікуєте, що у
вас є коефіцієнти правильності  показав
нам 0,84, щоб збільшити або зменшити
так, дякую
за ваше запитання,
я справді думаю, що воно
буде пов’язане, тому що
наш прогноз
може спостерігати, що це 18 валюта, яку
ми
[музика]
гм
за допомогою машинного навчання була модель
проаналізована
на дані
гм
чи ми використовуємо  дані про температуру, які ви знаєте,
листівка з днем ​​народження та кількість
опадів, займенники,
добре, у другому питанні, дякую, а
друге запитання стосується
клієнтів, тому ви згадали, що
з того, що я чув і з того, що ви
написали, основна
категорія клієнтів  для вас Трейдери є зерновими
трейдерами, чи
можете ви розповісти нам зразок випадку, як це
буде використано, як це допоможе їм
вести бізнес,
як ця модель покращить їхні
прибутки чи, скажімо, зменшить їхні
збитки
щось подібне,
дякую,
звичайні трейдери купують  прогноз,
а потім знову продати його іншим великим
компаніям, наприклад, компанія каже,
що це буде високий прибуток, це
означає, що вони можуть інвестувати та
отримають прибуток,
чим більше інвестицій залучено до
сільськогосподарського сектора, тим кращий
Гарвард і хороший  прибуток
так, але під інвестиціями під інвестиціями ви маєте на увазі,
ну, скажімо, посадити більше насіння так у
ґрунт або чи так, добре, я
розумію, дякую, дякую,
дуже дякую, ваше запитання, дякую
за проект, чи плануєте ви масштабувати
і поширюйте згаданий метод серед
інших груп не тільки з
вами, ні,
ви не плануєте, так,
добре, дякую,
велике спасибі, а тепер наш останній, але
не менш важливий стартап Trail up,
привіт усім,
так, ви можете побачити мою презентацію, так, звичайно
ви можете почати добре одного вечора, я всім привіт, мене
звуть Марта, і мій партнер
Андрій також готував цей проект,
тож давайте поговоримо про нас.
Одного разу
наша команда складається зі студентів другого курсу
біотехнології та дубайської
інженерії, які працюють на полях
мікроконтального відтворення наш науковий
керівник кандидат технічних і
наук між ідеями Романа або тисячоліття
ідея проекту була
розроблена на тлі інших
особистих досліджень економічного
становища агрономії в Україні ми хочемо
допомогти агрономії вийти на новий рівень
клітин з  допомога мікроклонального
розмноження,
тому наша схема бізнес-моделі K Партнери
наші постачальники є продавцями компонентів
для продукту та упаковки ми проводимо
дослідження в партнерських лабораторіях цінність
пропозиції та запрошуємо
біотехнологічний метод отримання
яблук і однолітків щотижня екологічно
та ретельно, зберігаючи
ступінь біорізноманіття  у вартості K Resorts
сировина для отримання живильного
середовища та сам продукт проведення
досліджень проведення та експертиза fnc
людські та інтелектуальні ресурси,
отже, це ціна Apple Tree sibling
Champion коштує один долар 30 центів, але
яблуня sibling Champion вирощується
методом in vitro коштує 2 долари  50 центів, але
ці методи мають привілей на
товарному ринку ви матимете більше врожаю
та o0 вартості для агрохімікатів
перевага відтворення in vitro
здорова заміна очищена Opera та
бактеріальна інфекція швидке вирощування
активне зростання протягом цього року
збереження сорту вихідних
матеріалів  для розмноження є ідентичним
оригіналу,
тому в нашому плані є кілька особливих
етапів у цій технології, які необхідно
дотримуватися для отримання бажаного результату,
потрібно розуміти, що нехтування
послідовністю дій або певним смородом
може призвести до зовсім іншого результату,
ніж очікує селекціонер  по-перше,
відбір донора, по-друге, розмноження,
розвиток і адаптація,
тож що вам потрібно, пояснення
та чашка Петрі та дорівнює, у нас
понад 8 000 клонів,
тож дякуємо, що вислухали, зв’яжіться з нами,
дуже дякую, будь ласка, так, дякую,
дякую  Яна, ну, по-
перше, Мартін, дякую за
презентацію, це справді
цікава тема, і in vitro, ну,
вирощування рослин і насіння, ну,
щоб я міг краще зрозуміти, тепер
ви це науковий проект, він
народився з наукової цікавості
ваше власне дослідження, і ви хочете
оформити його, щоб передати, скажімо,
інтелектуальну власність і людей в якусь компанію та
продовжити розробку та масштабування
технології, яка була доведена, або вам потрібно
зараз довести фактичну життєздатність
технології в масштабі, який
ми маємо, ми
маємо  ми тільки це робимо, але ми можемо
знайти деяку інформацію про in vitro,
і я хочу сказати, що
в Україні є багато компаній, які використовують цей метод, але
їхні продукти не користуються попитом через
непопулярність і популярність, або продукти,
тому вони мають високі ціни, і
гм я  подумайте про поганий стратегічний план, тому що
агрономи в Україні не використовують їхню
продукцію, вони використовують продукцію з Німеччини,
Франції, але не з України, тому що в них
є деякі недоліки,
і що ви робите по-іншому у
вашому випадку порівняно з німецькими, скажімо,
компаніями, тож
ми будемо  дійсно хотілося створити
оптимальну ціну на наші продукти, яка
буде конкурентоспроможною зі Sprite за
цієї ціни з Європи та покриє
витрати на розробку, нижчі ціни
зацікавлять агрономів і
заохочуватимуть їх спробувати наші продукти,
наприклад, нижча ціна, яку ви
назвали дві ціни 1,3 долара  і 2,5
долара так, який з них підійде вам,
який з них застосовний для ваших
продуктів,
коштує три без використання окремих — це
дерево, яке містить віруси, і я
думаю, що е-е, і менше cropio два цілих півдолара,
це ціна за
німецьку технологію, засновану на Німеччині  базові
компанії в Україні мають багато любителів
вищі ціни близько трьох доларів,
добре, так, а для агрономів, як тільки вони
хочуть отримати більше врожаю, це дійсно
гм, вони справді витрачають більше
грошей, тому що
це більше,
і чи маєте ви останнє запитання?  у
вас є лабораторне обладнання, необхідне
для виконання всіх цих
заходів з розробки ресурсів
для більшого нам потрібні матеріали для вирощування
зараз
і, можливо, більше схоже на слабке обладнання для
Mars Heisman
і скільки в доларах, скільки
грошей вам потрібно, щоб покрити початкові
етапи,
досить важко підрахувати  тому що
все залежить від кількості та
масштабу виробництва, тому ми не
робимо дійсно круто, ми насправді не
розраховуємо цю ціну, тому що це залежить
від того,
скільки ми хочемо,
і, скажімо, на 1000 ну ви
згадали вісім-десять тисяч я  подумайте про
зразки так, я вважаю, що у вашій
презентації на одному з останніх слайдів
так, так, і давайте поділимо це
на тисячі, скільки вам це коштуватиме, чи
буде вам коштувати вирощування 10
000 зразків, отже, з 1000 зразками
вирішення його  матеріали це е-е,
не рахуйте зараз, е-е, це так,
але я думаю, що це
дійсно великі гроші, тому що
коли ви тільки починаєте робити це, ми
гм,
мені не потрібно переглядати свої речі, тому
не так нудно, щоб не хвилюватися, добре, і
останнє запитання, що  це ваша мотивація? Я
закінчу запитанням, яке було
моїм першим, яка ваша мотивація
прийти сьогодні на цей захід, що
ви шукаєте? Мотивовано, тому що ми
не допоможемо агрономам в Україні,
тому що
ми багато про це читаємо,
і я  знаю, що в Польщі вони дійсно
використовували ці методи, і вони купують
ці продукти в Україні, це не
популярно, я не знаю, чому, можливо, це
недешево, а
угоди в Україні не знаю,
чому вони повинні платити більше,
тому що це  дуже низький
Я хотів би подумати
тут про цей продукт
добре добре дякую дякую добре
добре дякую всім за цю
презентацію для вашої презентації та за
ваше запитання, тож тепер у нас буде 20
хвилин перерви, щоб члени мрії
завершили  переможців і почуйте їхні
імена, тож побачимося тут через 20 хвилин,
дякую,
дякую, тож привіт
усім, ми вже маємо
переможців, ми хочемо зазначити, що
через зменшення загальної кількості
учасників буде 10 переможців,
п’ять із Health Tech та  п’ять від
agrotech, але перш ніж оголосити їх, я
хотів би надати слово
членам журі, які сьогодні оцінювали стартапи
та поставили таке гарне запитання для
першого. Я хотів би запросити Майка
Халевскі, будь ласка, так, дякую,
дякую  Друзі, для
сьогоднішньої презентації я
брав участь лише в агротех, тому мої
коментарі відображатимуть те, що я
чув від агротех-стартапів, тож
перш за все я почув чудові ідеї
сьогодні, але пам’ятайте, що
ідея – це щось нематеріальне, що вам потрібно
показати журі  члени та подальші
інвестори фактичний продукт, отже,
реалізація ідеї, як ви це бачите,
і що вам знадобиться для досягнення
так, яке фінансування, які знання,
яка ще допомога вам може знадобитися
для досягнення, тож це перший коментар
і  другий коментар, не бійтеся
розміщувати більше інформації
на слайдах, так, тому що в
деяких презентаціях, як я почув
сьогодні, не вистачає важливих елементів,
так, перш за все вони запитують у
інвестора або в тієї сторони, до якої ви
звертаєтеся,
і тому  це речі, про які слід пам’ятати, і я
просто ризикнув, е-е, я домовився
з командою USF, я хотів би
також запросити вас взяти участь у нашій
польській українській стартовій команді Bridge,
яка я е-е-е,
комунікаційна програма прискорення
з польською  Український стартап
досягає програми, я є членом команди, на якій
ми зосереджуємося, скажімо, найважливішим
компонентом того, на чому ми зосереджуємося, є
фактична робота над вашими презентаціями,
робота над вашими документами, робота над
вашими фінансовими моделями під час нашої програми, у
нас ще залишилося шість днів
у крайній термін подачі заявок,
тож якщо ви хочете покращити елементи, про які
я згадав, або співпрацювати з нашими
менеджерами з Польщі та України,
будь ласка, до Андрія,
дякую, велике спасибі, Майк, і дякую за
всі ваші запитання, які були справді хорошими,
а тепер  кілька слів від Анджели
Джексон, будь ласка,
дякую всім, просто чудові
презентації та надихаючі ідеї, я
вважаю, що для мене це смиренно
сидіти тут, у США, і
розуміти всю стійкість і
все, через що ви проходите  просто бути
суворим підприємцем, яскравою
країною, мені подобаються молоді підприємці,
хм, з якими ми сьогодні спілкуємося, тож просто
пару порад, коли ви рухаєтесь
вперед,
хм, я думаю, зі свого боку як інвестора,
який виписує чеки, я завжди
слухаю  для
перетворення ідей університету на
більш відчутний продукт, тому в якості
наступних кроків, на мою думку, у багатьох презентаціях критично не вистачало
будь-якого
контакту з клієнтами,
тож проведення розмов із потенційними
майбутніми клієнтами, проведення
детальних опитувань навіть для того, щоб дізнатися про
ціни чи
поведінку щодо впровадження, оскільки  у нас є фраза,
яка нам не подобається: «будуй це, і
вони прийдуть». Це
просто неправда,
гм, нам доводиться взаємодіяти з клієнтами
та ринком на кожному кроці, щоб
переконатися, що ми створюємо правильну річ,
яка  клієнти та ринок хочуть,
окрім цього, невелика підказка, яку я б
сказав у короткій презентації, скажімо,
п’ять хвилин, а потім три хвилини q a
деякі з найкращих деталей, які я почув сьогодні,
випадково пролунали через запитання та відповіді, що, якщо, що, якби суддя зробив
не ставте це питання, тож
пам’ятайте, що у вашій
презентації потрібно приділяти все, а не стільки часу, потрібного на постановку
проблеми, ми хочемо
швидше дістатися до формулювання рішення та про те,
що таке ваша унікальна авеню,
ваше унікальне бачення,
так що це все  Я, чесно кажучи, дуже
вражений, і я думаю, що у вас усіх є
яскраве підприємницьке майбутнє. Дякую,
велике вам дякую, Анжела, дякую, що ви
з нами, і дякую за вашу
увагу до українських стартапів і за
можливості для них і нашого останнього
судді, який я вважаю правим  Тепер старший
краковіч, ласкаво просимо. Спершу кілька
слів нашим стартапам.
Я мав надіслати всім стартапам, ви
чудові люди та чудова команда, тому що
ви створюєте чудові інноваційні рішення в
такий складний час, тож сьогодні ми герої,
дякую вам усім, а також я  Хочу
подякувати Українському фонду стартапів
за співпрацю з нами в цьому
спільному проекті наука та бізнес і
окрема вдячність за суть підтримки
цієї ініціативи, дякую і
бажаю успіхів у розвитку всім
стартапам, ви всі чудові, і
все буде з вашими ідеями  Я,
мабуть, кожного тижня,
дуже дякую, і тепер переможці в
охороні здоров’я, які ми маємо в Тампі, перевіряємо,
тварини, лісові пожежі, ти і
помічник у здоров’ї, мої вітання,
в агротехнічному треку, у нас є так,
харчовий парасток агробон Штрауса та біогенне
срібло, мої вітання всім переможцям
сьогодні
так, я дуже вдячний за вашу
увагу, до зустрічі в наступних виступах
і найкращих побажань з Українським
фондом стартапів, до зустрічі,
дякую, до побачення,
велике спасибі, дякую за
можливість бути тут, гарного дня, до побачення,
дякую,
так, велике спасибі  до побачення, дякую